ओके सो आई थिंक वी आर लाइव गाइस वी आर
लाइव
नाउ
मबल
ओके या सो वी आर लाइव नाउ गाइस लेट मी
सेंड दिस टू आ ् चैनल
टू तो चलिए हम लाइव आ चुके
हैं फाइनली एंड प्लीज लेट मी नो इफ ऑडिबल
एंड विजिबल तो एक बार बता दीजिए सभी चैट
में मेरी आवाज बिल्कुल क्लियर जा रही है
क्या प्लीज लेट मी नो मैं एक बार चेक भी
कर लेता हूं दूसरे फोन पे एक बार लेट मी
चेक
वंस
के जल्दी से सभी को पहले आ जाने देते हैं
फिर स्टार्ट करते हैं क्योंकि काफी
इंपोर्टेंट सेशन है आज का काफी मजा आने
वाला है
सबको ठीक है आई थिंक आई थिंक एवरी बडी
लाइव नाउ ओके वी आर गुड टू गो राइट आई
थिंक वी आर गुड टू गो
राइट चलिए
तो गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग सभी को गुड
इवनिंग हे बड़ी व्ट्स ए केटी एन हेलो हेलो
ब्रदर हेलो गुड इवनिंग फर्स्ट टाइम
जॉइनिंग क्या बात है वेलकम
वेलकम चलिए तो आज जो है स्टार्ट करेंगे
प्रिविलेज एलेशन आर सो इंपोर्टेंट इन बग
बाउटी बिल्कुल करेंगे भाई उसको भी करेंगे
जो चीजें इंपॉर्टेंट है सबको करेंगे
ज्यादा टेंशन नहीं लेनी है सब चीजें हम
कवर करने वाले हैं तो बेफिक्र होके आपको
बस फॉलो अप करना है दैट्ची है तो लास्ट
सेशन में हमने काफी इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें
देखी थी हम आज के सेशन भी स्टार्ट करेंगे
ब उसके पहले सभी को पहले जवाइन करने देते
हैं काफी कम लोगों ने अभी जवाइन करा है तो
लेट एवरीबॉडी जॉइन ठीक है बाकी लोग कहां
चले गए भाई बाकी लोगों को बुलाओ जल्दी से
बुलाओ जल्दी से बुला लो बाकी लोगों को
ताकि हम स्टार्ट कर पाए राइट 50 50 प्लस
भी नहीं हुए अभी
तो जल्दी आ
जाओ हरी अप गाइस हरी
अप चलिए मैंने य मैसेज
भी वो कर दिया है सो आई होप एवरी बडी विल
जॉइन फास्ट
ओके सो 35 पीपल हैव जॉइड सभी को लाइन देते
हैं तभी स्टार्ट करेंगे अपन कम से कम
एटलीस्ट 50 प्लस तो आ ही जाने आ ही जाने
देते हैं फिर स्टार्ट भी कर देंगे सो आई
एम सीइंग
द चैट राइट
ओके 37 पीपल आर हियर अ सो ऑफलाइन का सब हो
गया क्या अभी बचाओ अभी तो टाइम बचा अभी तो
कवन 2025 क्वार्टर व 2025 तक होगी सारी
चीजें लच राइट
करेक्ट करेक्ट करेक्ट आप लोगों
को जो चीजें मैं बता रहा हूं जो चीजें मैं
सिखा रहा हूं वह गोल्डन चीजें सिखा रहा
हूं मैं आपको आपको प्राइसलेस चीजें बता
रहा हूं आप उसको अगर सही से अगर आप लिटरली
यू आर वेरी मच इनटू लर्निंग वेरी मच इनटू
लाइक दिस थिंग्स लाइक बग बाउंटीज एंड ऑल
एंड आप सिंसियर सीखना चाहते हैं तो आपके
लिए फिर यह एक गोल्ड माइन है एक तरह से आप
कह सकते हैं एंड यू विल बी लर्निंग अ लॉट
ऑफ थिंग्स हियर राइट तो यहां पे हमारा
डेनिक्स का लिंकन पेज है आप इसको जरूर
फॉलो अप कर लीजिएगा जो भी कंपनी से
रिलेटेड अपडेट्स हैं आपको इसी पेज पे मिल
जाएंगी एंड हमारी यह वाली जो है यह इसकी
यूआरएल है आप यहां पे जाके डेनिक सर्च
करके ्र साइबर सिक्योरिटी आप इसको फॉलो अप
कर सकते हैं राइट तो लास्ट सेशन में हमने
बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें देखी थी हमने
लास्ट सेशन में देखा था हाउ टू व्हाट इज
न्यूक्लि आई व्हाट इज न्यूक्लि आई देन
देखा था हमने हाउ टू यूज न्यूक्लि आई टू
फाइंड वनबिल ठीक
है एंड देयर आर अ लॉट ऑफ थिंग्स दैट वी सॉ
देर र लॉट ऑफ थिंग्स ट वी स इन द लास्ट
सेशन राइट तो अब जो है आज के सेशन में ठीक
है सर मैं लेक्चर वन से देखना स्टार्ट
किया है इसलिए लाइव पर आकर देख नहीं सकता
कोई बात नहीं कोई बात नहीं कोई बात नहीं
चलेगा कोई दिक्कत नहीं आज काफी कम लोग आए
हैं क्या बात है भाई आज सब छुट्टियों में
है क्या यह तो बताओ
सब मतलब सब छुट्टियों में है
क्या सब दशाहरा दुर्गा
पूजा इन सब में लगे हुए हैं
क्या
ओ घरबा खेलने गए हैं मतलब आज आज आज आज ही
होती है क्या हां आई थिंक फेस्टिवल में ही
होंगे
बिजी सभी लोग फेस्टिवल को एंजॉय कर रहे
हैं कोई बात नहीं कोई बात नहीं चलेगा सवल
एंजॉय कर रहा है अच्छी बात है तो एटलीस्ट
50 प्लस आने देते हैं देन स्टार्ट करते हो
राइट गैप कम कर दो गैप देखो गैप कम करने
की बात नहीं है यहां पे बात ये है मैं तो
बहुत फ्रीक्वेंसी
क्लासेस ला दूंगा इतना टाइम तो मैं निकाल
ही लूंगा मैं बिजी भी रहूंगा फिर भी मैं
इतना टाइम निका लूंगा कि फ्रीक्वेंसी लेकर
आ पाऊंगा ठीक है बट स्टिल वो ना आपके लिए
कोई बेनिफिशियल नहीं होने वाला है लिटरली
मैं बता रहा हूं आपको नॉट एट ऑल
बेनिफिशियल फॉर एवरीवन क्योंकि यहां पे
बहुत सारे जो से सीखने वाले हैं ना वो
बहुत बिगिन लेवल के स्टूडेंट्स हैं जो
बिगिनर्स हैं जो न्यूबीज हैं जिनको ज्यादा
कुछ आईडिया नहीं है तो वो जब एक वीडियो को
या एक बग को कंप्लीट करते हैं तो उनसे मैं
रिक्वेस्ट करता हूं कि बस तुरंत जंप ऑन ना
कर दे एक साथ 50 बग को नहीं देखना नहीं
सीखना है आपको एक बग के बारे में जब आपने
सीखा एक वल्नरेबल के बारे में आपने जब
सीखा तो उस पे प्रैक्टिस करें उसके
रिसोर्सेस को एक्सप्लोर करें और भी
एक्सप्लोर करें अपनी ची अपने तरीके से एंड
देखें कि उसमें और क्या-क्या चीजें आप कर
सक सकते हैं उस परे प्रैक्टिसेस करें
लैब्स को सॉल्व करें रियल वर्ल्ड
वेबसाइट्स को टारगेट की तरह भी जहां पर
आपको परमिशन है वहां पर आप उसको यूज करें
देखें कि भैया आपके अंदर एक्चुअली में आप
कितना अच्छा उसको एग्जीक्यूट कर पा रहे
हैं आप कितने अच्छे से उसको एग्जीक्यूट कर
पा रहे यह सब चीज आपको थोड़ी देखनी पड़ेगी
राइट ओके लाइव स्ट्रीम में कोई इशू तो
नहीं आ रही है लाइव स्ट्रीम बीच में रुक
तो नहीं रही है ना एक बार बता दीजिए आप
लोग एक बार बता जी लाइव स्ट्रीम बीच में
रुक रही है क्या या सही चल रही
है ठीक है ना सही चल रही है ना ओके चलो
ठीक है ठीक है ओके ग्रेट चलिए 42 पीपल आर
हियर नाउ वी विल बी स्टार्टिंग एंड टुडे
हम थोड़ी सी एडवांस के तरफ जाने वाले हैं
ठीक है न्यूक्लि आई के कुछ हम एडवांस
पार्ट को समझने वाले हैं तो हम सिर्फ
एडवांस पार्ट यानी कि कस्टम न्यूक्लि
टेंप्लेट कैसे क्रिएट किया जा सकता है या
आप कस्टम न्यूक्लि टेंप्ट खुद का टेंप्लेट
कैसे क्रिएट कर सकते हैं यह आप कर सकते
हैं बिल्कुल अब देखो न्यूक्लि आई जो है ना
न्यूक्लि अपने आप में एक गो लैंग्वेज में
बनी हुई टूल है गो पे बनी हुई गो पे बेस
टूल है बट इसके अंदर जो टेंपलेट्स काम
करते हैं उनको वाईएमएल समझ में आता है ठीक
है वाईएमएल भी एक मार्कअप लैंग्वेज है एज
मैंने ऑलरेडी आपको बताया हुआ है कि मैं आप
वाईएमएल लर्निंग प आप जाएंगे तो यहां पर
आपको सिंपली इसके ट्यूटोरियल ट्यूटोरियल
पॉइंट प आपको टोरियल भी मिल जाएंगे ठीक है
तो यहां पे आपको वाईएमएल का एक सिंपल सा
ट्यूटोरियल जो है वो यहां पर मिल जाएगा कि
किस तरीके से यह काम करती है बहुत ही
ह्यूमन रीडेबल फॉर्म में ये इसके जो
सिंटेक्स है वो ह्यूमन रीडेबल फॉर्म है
एंड बहुत ही इजी टू अंडरस्टैंड है ठीक है
तो आप इसको बहुत ज्यादा डिटेल में जाने की
जरूरत नहीं है आप थोड़ी बहुत चीजों को देख
लेंगे समझ जाएंगे वाईएमएल आपका या एमल
बहुत लोग एमएल बोलते हैं बहुत लोग वाईएमएल
बोलते हैं वो आपका परफेक्ट हो जाएगा तो यह
एक आयरन है राइट ये एक आयरन है ठीक है
आयनी क्या है यहां पर अभी देख लीजिए मैं
उधर मैं चैट सब नहीं देख रहा ठीक
है सर सारे टेंपलेट्स यूज कर लिए 121
वेबसाइट पे बग मिल ही नहीं रहा यह बहुत
देखो सबसे पहली बात आपको न्यूक्लि के सारे
टेंपलेट्स एक साथ एक वेबसाइट प नहीं यूज
करने हैं बहुत सारे जो टेंपलेट्स होते हैं
उसमें बहुत तरह की दिक्कतें आती हैं एंड
बहुत सारे टेंप्लेट जब आप यूज करेंगे तो
आपको वह वेबसाइट या जो सर्वर है वो आपके
रिक्वेस्ट को ब्लॉक करनी शुरू कर देगी ठीक
है जब आप एक्सेसिव अमाउंट ऑफ रिक्वेस्ट
करते हैं तो उसके भी कुछ तरीके हैं रेट
लिमिटिंग का यूज आप कर सकते हैं इसके अंदर
में वो भी मैं अभी आपको समझा दूंगा
प्रॉपर्ली किस तरीके से यूज करना है देन
शायद आप अच्छा वहां पे उसको एग्जीक्यूट कर
पाएंगे ठीक है चलिए तो अब यहां पे एक चीज
मैं बताता हूं आपको पिछले सेशन में हमने
न्यूक्लि के बारे में बेसिक जानकारी ली थी
न्यूक्लि का यूज केस पढ़ा था कैसे यूज कर
सकते हैं वो सारी चीजें पढ़ी थी उसको
एग्जीक्यूट करके हमने वेबसाइट पे भी टेस्ट
करी थी अभी हम जो है इस सेशन में कस्टम
न्यूक्लि आई टेंप्लेट कैसे बना सकते सकते
हैं इस पे फोकस करेंगे अब मैंने आपको
ऑलरेडी बताया था न्यूक्लि गो में बनी हुई
है बट टेंप्लेट इसके वा एमएल को समझते हैं
वाईएमएल एक बहुत इजी टू
अंडरस्टैंड एक मार्क अप लैंग्वेज है जिसको
आप समझ सकते हैं और खुद के टेंपलेट्स बना
सकते हैं अब ये क्रिएटिंग कस्टम टेंप्लेट
बनाने का क्या मतलब है ठीक है व्हाट इज
व्हाट डज इट मींस तो देखो कस्टम टेंपलेट्स
न्यूक्लि आई के अंदर में जब तुम न्यूक्लि
को ओपन करो जैसे मैं अभी ओपन कर रहा हूं
राइट तो लेट मी ओपन द काली मशीन मेरी काली
मशीन ओपन करते हैं देन न्यूक्लियर को ओपन
करते हैं उसके अंदर
में देखो मैं आज की सेशन भी सोच रहा था कि
अभी एक दो दिन सेशन नहीं लूंगा अ ड्यू टू
द फेस्टिवल सीजन ऑन गोइंग क्योंकि मुझे
पता था काफी लोग इसमें बिजी रहते हैं
फेस्टिव सीजन में होते हैं दिमाग इधर-उधर
होता है तो शायद इस पे उनत कंसंट्रेट नहीं
करेंगे फिर भी मैंने आज क्लास एक ले ली है
अ जो लोग नहीं अभी आ पाए फेस्टिवल के कारण
वो रिकॉर्डिंग ही देखेंगे इसकी बट स्टिल
आई बिलीव एंड आई होप कि आप नेक्स्ट टाइम
लाइव को अटेंड करेंगे ठीक है तो यहां पे
जब आप न्यूक्लि टूल को इंस्टॉल कर लेते
हैं सिंपल सा फंडा है आपको पता है कैसे
इंस्टॉल करना है सिंपल आपको प सेशन पिछले
सेशन में बता दिया था तो जब आप यहां पे
जाएंगे तो रूट के अंदर में या होम
डायरेक्टरी में आपके तो लोकल के अंदर में
डॉट लोकल के अंदर में आपको न्यूक्लियर
टेंपलेट्स मिलते हैं ये जो टेंपलेट्स आपको
बने मिले पड़ रहे हैं ना ये जैसे क्लाउड
के कोड डीएसटी के डीएनएस के फाइल के
हैडलेस हेल्पर्स एचटीटीपी के ये टेंपलेट्स
भी किसी ने डेवलप किए हैं बनाए हैं तो जब
आप इन टेंपलेट्स के अंदर जाएंगे जैसे मैं
एटीपी के अंदर जा रहा हूं मैं जा रहा हूं
एक्सपोजर के अंदर में अब एक्सपोजर के अंदर
में आ रहा है मान लो कॉन्गस अब कॉफिक्स के
अंदर में यहां पे बहुत सारे कॉन्फ़िग के
टेंपलेट्स हैं ठीक है एक्सपोजर कॉन्फ़िग
एक्सपोजर के अब
देखो यहां
पे उ मैं कोई सा भी एक कॉन्फ़िग उठाता हूं
जैसे
कि चलो यहां पे उठाते हैं कग
properties.com
आपको एक कोड देखने को मिलेगा अब यही
टेंप्लेट है एंड इसी को हम वाईएमएल या
एमएल बोलते हैं एंड एमएल में यह बना हुआ
है वाईएमएल में ये बना हुआ है इसकी
सिंटेक्स बहुत इजी टू यूज है अब न्यूक्लि
आई जो है वो बहुत ही तरह के कीवर्ड्स को
सपोर्ट करता है इसके अंदर में वाईएमएल के
साथ मिलके ठीक है तो यहां पे सबसे पहले
आपको आईडी देनी होती है इंफो देनी होती है
फिर उसके बाद रिक्वेस्ट या जो आपका
प्रोटोकॉल है वो यहां पे मेंशन करना होता
है देन उसी के अंदर में आप अलग-अलग तरह के
मैचस फिर एक्स्ट्रा टर्स वगैरह यूज करते
हैं ठीक है फिलहाल यहां पे सिर्फ मैचर्स
एंड मैट्रेस कंडीशंस यूज हुए हैं
एक्सट्रैक्टर्स यहां पे यूज नहीं हुए हैं
बट आप उसको यूज कर सकते हैं इफ यू वांट
राइट तो इस तरीके से ये टेंपलेट्स बनती है
अब न्यूक्लि के टेंप्लेट को खुद से बनाने
का क्या मतलब है इसका आपको मीनिंग मैं
आपको समझाता हूं कि खुद का भाई टेंप्लेट
क्यों बनाना है इसको आप समझिए थोड़ा तो जब
हम ऑफिशियल प्रोजेक्ट डिस्कवरी के वेबसाइट
प आएंगे देखो मैं आपको एक चीज बताता हूं
जब आप कोई टूल को यूज करते हैं कोई भी एक
ओपन सोर्स टूल है और उसके डेवलपर ने उसको
अच्छे तरीके से प्रोड्यूस करके अच्छे तरी
से तरीके से मार्केट में उसको लॉन्च किया
है तो उसके रिगार्डिंग हर एक डिटेल हर एक
चीज वो अवेलेबल कराएगा उसके डॉक्यूमेंटेशन
उसके हाउ टू यूज केस हाउ टू इंस्टॉल हाउ
टू एग्जीक्यूट कैसे सब कुछ अवेलेबल कराएगा
न्यूक्लि का खुद का जो ब्लॉग है आप उस
ब्लॉग पे जब आप आएंगे तो यहां पे लिखा है
द अल्टीमेट गाइड टू फाइंडिंग बग्स विथ
न्यूक्लि इसमें जब आप आएंगे तो आपको बहुत
सारे यहां पे चैप्टर्स मिलेंगे या
कंटेंट्स मिलेंगे इसमें आपको पूरी
न्यूक्लि आई के अंदर जो जो चीजें आप कर
सकते हैं बहुत ही डिटेल में दी हुई है इसी
में एक पार्ट आता है आपका कस्टम टेंपलेट्स
का जो कि अपने आप में एक बहुत डिटेल टॉपिक
है एंड यहां पे कस्टम टेंपलेट्स पे जब आप
आएंगे तो आपको यहां पे हर एक जानकारी मिल
जाएगी बट क्योंकि आप अगर जब इतनी चीजें को
पढ़ेंगे तो आपका दिमाग जो है इधर-उधर
घूमने लगेगा बहुत सारे ऐसे लोगों का होगा
बहुत सारे बिगिनर्स का होता है बहुत सारे
बिगिनर्स के साथ इशू ये होता है कि हर एक
चीज अवेलेबल है ऑनलाइन इंटरनेट पे अवेलेबल
है बट वो खुद से पढ़ के समझ नहीं पाते हैं
ज्यादातर दिक्कतें उनको आती है उस केस में
उनको चाहिए होती है मेंटरशिप को चाहिए
होता है एक मेंटर जो उनको अच्छे से गाइड
कर दे प्रॉपर्ली उनको रास्ता दिखा दे एंड
उनको समझा दे कि कैसे आपको उस रास्ते पर
चलना है
दैट्ची रहा है ठीक है दैट्ची
जब आप कोई एक न्यू सीवी मान लो आपने कोई
एक न्यू सीवी फाइंड किया या आपने देखा कि
कोई एक न्यू सीवी डिस्कवर हुई है तो आपने
क्या किया उसके उसको पढ़ा या आपका है खुद
का तो आपको पता ही है व्हिच
डेमोंस्ट्रेट्स अ सिंपल प्रूफ ऑफ कंसेप्ट
एंड नो वन हैज रिटन अ न्यूक्लि टेंप्लेट ट
मतलब उस सीवी के ऊपर में किसी ने अभी तक
टेंप्लेट नहीं लिखा है ठीक है अब आपने उस
सीवी को पढ़ा उसकी प्रूफ ऑफ कंसेप्ट को
पढ़ा कि भैया ये पर्टिकुलर वनबिल ये जो एक
नई टाइप की वनबिल उस बंदे ने आपने फाइंड
की है
वो किस तरीके से फाइंड हुई है उसी
कांसेप्ट को उठा के आपके टेंप्लेट में डाल
के और टेंप्लेट को बोलेंगे कि टारगेट
वेबसाइट को रिक्वेस्ट करो और देखो कि उस
पर्टिकुलर टारगेट वेबसाइट के अंदर में वो
वनबिल एजिस्ट करती है कि नहीं करती है दैट
स इ सीवी का मतलब आपको ऑलरेडी पता है ठीक
है ऐसी कोई बताने की जरूरत नहीं है सिंपल
सा एक बोल सकते हो कि एक लिंक है एक डटा
है एक डेटाबेस है जहां पे आप जो भी एक
जीरो डे या जो भी ऐसी लेबिलिटी आप न्यू वल
एबिलिटीज फाइंड करते हो तो उसको एक जगह
स्टोर करके एक उसको असाइन किया जाता है एक
नंबर एंड उस नंबर के अकॉर्डिंग उस नंबर के
हिसाब से आप उसको फाइंड कर सकते हो एंड
पहचानते हो जानते हो कि भैया हां ये वाली
पर्टिकुलर वल्नरेबल है इस सीवी की अब यहां
पे यू फाइंड एन जीरो डे वल्नरेबल
योरसेल्फ बहुत अच्छी बात है भाई आपने जीरो
डे वलने बिलिटी फाइंड की एंड वांट टू अलाउ
अदर्स टू स्कैन होस्ट फॉर प्रेजेंस ऑफ द
इशू एंड आप दूसरे को अलाउ करते हो कि भैया
इस इशू को आप स्कैन कर सकते हो यू डिस्कवर
अ नोवल अटैक वेक्टर एंड पेलो दैट वर्क क्स
ऑन द टारगेट ठीक है आपने कोई एक अटैक
वेक्टर या एक पेलोड को डिस्कवर कर लिया जो
एक टारगेट पे आपके रन करता है ठीक है ना
अब यहां पे एंड यू वांट टू इन्वेस्टिगेट
वेदर द सेम इश्यूज अफेक्ट्स डिफरेंट
लाइब्रेरीज और वेबसाइट्स और डिफरेंट
टारगेट यानी आपने एक वेबसाइट पे कोई चीज
काम कर रही है मान लो कोई आपने अटैक किया
कोई एक वेक्टर कोई पेलोड है एक वेबसाइट पे
तो काम कर दिया अब आप चाहते हो नहीं यार
सारी वेबसाइट पे ये लोगों को चेक करना
चाहिए तो आप सारी वेबसाइट्स पे तो चेक
नहीं कर सकते ना कि आप ही जाओ सारी
वेबसाइट पे तो आपने एक न्यूक्लि टेंप्लेट
बना दिया अब न्यूक्लि आई टूल हजारों लोग
यूज़ कर रहे हैं तो न्यूक्लि टूल के अंदर
हजारों लोगों ने उस टेंपलेट्स को हजारों
बार हजारों वेबसाइट्स पे ट्राई किया अब इस
तरीके से हजारों वेबसाइट्स की चेकिंग हो
गई आपको कुछ नहीं करना है तो आप उस केस
में न्यूक्लि के टेंप्लेट को डेवलप कर
सकते हो और आप बहुत इजली उसको डेवलप करके
और इसको टेस्ट भी कर सकते हो
चलिए अब यहां पे अ देखते हैं यहां पे अभी
फिलहाल तो आप अ टेंप्लेट को मैनुअली बनाते
हो वाईएमएल के थ्रू अब प्रोजेक्ट डिस्कवरी
का एक क्लाउड प्लेटफॉर्म भी रेडी होने
वाला है बहुत जल्द हालांकि वो रेडी हो
चुका है आप इसका अ इसका आप वो ले सकते हो
लाइक यूज ट्राई कर सकते हो ठीक है ना यहां
पे तो ट्राई कर सकते हो कि कैसे इसको वो
करना है तो आप इसका ट्रायल या जो भी है वो
ट्राई कर सकते हो ठीक है तो यहां पे अब इस
टेंप्लेट को जब आप लिखोगे वाईएमएल जो ये
कस्टम टेंप्लेट है इसको लिखोगे तो इसका
मेनली चार पार्ट होता है इस टेंप्लेट का
मेन चार पार्ट होता है एक होती है आईडी एक
होती है इंफो टेंप्लेट की एक होती है कौन
सी डाटा सेंड करनी है व्हाट डेटा टू सेंड
टू रिमोट होस्ट एंड दूसरा होता है
इंस्ट्रक्शंस
ऑन हाउ टू एनालाइज द रिस्पांस रिस्पांस जो
आती है उसको कैसे एनालाइज करके एंड उसके
बेसिस पे आउटपुट देना है यानी कि हमें जो
चाहिए वह निकाल लेना है वहां से ट्स इट
ठीक है तो यह समझ में आ गया यहां पे
आपको टेंप्लेट
गाइड क्या स्टेप्स होते हैं टेंप्लेट के
पहला जो होता है क्या होता है टेंप्लेट की
आईडी होती है दूसरा जो होता है लेट की
इंफो होती है उसके बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन
तीसरा होता है व्हाट डाटा टू सेंड टू
रिमोट होस्ट यह होता है और चौथा क्या होता
है हाउ टू एनालाइज द रिस्पांस फ्रॉम रिमोट
होस्ट यह चार स्टेप्स में टेंपलेट्स आपके
बनते हैं इसी चारों स्टेप में पूरी की
पूरी टेंप्लेट बनती है चाहे वो कितनी भी
बड़ी टेंप्लेट हो उससे मैटर नहीं करता है
उससे कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ता है राइट सभी लोग
समझ पा रहे हैं को पहले यह बता दीजिए
मुझे हा न सखिया पीपल इज इक्वल टू 25000
लर्नर्स 13 के हु एजिस्ट टिल एंड ठीक है
100 एंड एक्चुअल हंटर्स
30 टिल एंड 100 एक्चुअल हंटर्स 30 दिस इज
रियली रियलिटी सो हैव पेशेंस बिकॉज दिस इज
साइबर सिक्योरिटी एंड कंसिस्टेंसी इज
इंपोर्टेंट बिल्कुल सही बात है नौसिखिया
जी कंसिस्टेंसी ना हो तो फिर कुछ नहीं कर
पाएंगे कंसिस्टेंसी के बिना तो कुछ भी
पॉसिबल नहीं आज के टाइम में सर आई गट टू
हॉल ऑ फेम इन बैकग्राउंड एंड वन मेंशन यू
ऑन लिंक न बट यू डोंट कमेंट वाई सर ललित
सिंह अच्छा आपने कांग्रेचुलेशन ललित
एक्चुअली मैंने देखा नहीं होगा ललित मैं
जैसे ही देखूंगा बिल्कुल आई विल बी
इंटरेक्ट विद दैट एंड मेनी मेनी
कांग्रेचुलेशन आपको हॉल ऑफ मिला है दो दो
बक क्राउड प वाओ
ग्रेट या नो नौ सखिया इस बंदे को काफी
मेहनत करता है बेचारा काफी ज्यादा लगा
पड़ा हुआ है राइट
दैट्ची डॉक्यूमेंट से पढ़ा है और कुछ नहीं
डॉक्यूमेंट को पढ़ जो जिसने पढ़ लिया समझ
लिया वो सब कुछ जान गया दैट्ची
से उन्होंने ही तैयार किया एक तरह से मान
लो ना या जो डेवलपर बोल लो कोडर बोल लो
उन्होंने तैयार किया है अब उनसे बेटर कौन
लिख सकता है किसी टूल के बारे में अब हमने
साइक्स को डेवलप किया राइट हमने किसको
डेवलप किया हमने हमारे
टूल साइक्स सर्च किया यहां पे साइबो निक्स
को यहां पे डेवलप किया ठीक है यहां पे आप
देख सकते हैं ये हमारी टूल है हमारी
स्टूडेंट्स के तरफ से बनाया हुआ ये टूल है
बहुत ही अमेजिंग टूल है देख सकते हैं 359
स्टर्स 74 फॉक्स ये चीज सानिस 3.2 लच हुई
थी अभी रिसेंटली जब हमारा डीसीएसपी का
सेकंड बैच ओवर हुआ था
राइट अब आप देख सकते हैं य पे साइबो निक्स
के अंदर में अब यहां पर क्या इसको कैसे
यूज करना है किस तरीके से इसको एग्जीक्यूट
करना है यह हमसे बेटर कौन बता सकता है कोई
और नहीं बता सकता कोई भी और बताएगा तो
हमसे ही सोच समझ के और पढ़ के बताएगा या
हमारे ही थ्रू हमारे ही रिसोर्सेस के थ्रू
बता पाएगा
राइट तो चार स्टेप्स है अब यहां पे देखिए
यहां पे एक एग्जांपल टेंप्लेट का एंड इसको
मैं एक्सप्लेन थोड़ा करता हूं फिर आपको ना
बहुत अच्छे से समझ में आएगा कि एटली
टेंप्लेट कैसे काम कर रहे हैं
राइट
ओके तो चलिए अब मैं आपको समझाता हूं यहां
प एक एग्जांपल टेंप्लेट है अब इस टेंप्लेट
में सबसे पहले है आईडी यानी कि इस
टेंप्लेट का आप आईडी यानी कि क्या आप आईडी
इसको असाइन करना चाहते
हो वो आईडी आप यहां पर असाइन कर दो आप कुछ
भी आईडी दे सकते हो जनरली जब भी आप किसी
पर्टिकुलर वलने बिलिटी के रिगार्डिंग बना
रहे हो आप उसी के रिगार्डिंग कोई आईडी
असाइन कर दो नाम फैमिलियर नेम दैट वुड बी
मच बेटर आईडी के बाद इंफॉर्मेशन आती है
आईडी के बाद क्या आती है इंफॉर्मेशन आती
है अब इंफॉर्मेशन के अंदर में क्या-क्या
चीजें होती हैं यहां पे नेम आप दे सकते हो
टेंप्लेट का जो भी आपको जैसे कि आप नेम
देना है वो नेम दे दो जैसे जो भी आप
पर्टिकुलर वलने बिटी के अगेंस्ट बना रहे
हो उस उसके अलाइड नेम यहां पे प्रोवाइड कर
दो ऑथर अब उसका ऑथर कौन है तो आप आप अपना
नाम या जो भी उसका पर्टिकुलर ऑथर या आप
खुद ही कर रहे हो तो आप अपना नाम लिख
दीजिए सीवियरिंग कौन सी देनी है तो
न्यूक्लि के अंदर मैंने आपको ऑलरेडी बताया
हुआ है जब आप न्यूक्लि के हेल्प फाइल को
ओपन
करेंगे हां तो न्यूक्लि के हेल्प फाइल
में यहां पे तो आप न्यूक्लियर की हेल्थ
फाइल में देखेंगे सीवियरिंग तो यहां पे
आपको सीवियरिंग में दिख जाएगी इंफो जो कि
इंफॉर्मेशन हो गया बहुत ही लो कैटेगरी का
एक हो गया एक मीडियम एक हाई एक क्रिटिकल
और एक अननोन भी है यहां पे मतलब अगर ये
पहचान नहीं पा रहा है कि कौन सी सीवियरिंग
का है तो अननोन यहां पे यहां पे ये मेंशन
होके बेसिकली आ जाता है ठीक है तो ये
सीवियरिंग जो है आप यहां पे इस टेंप्लेट
के अंदर में डिफाइन कर सकते हैं कौन सा है
वो आपके ऊपर है आपको जो लेबिलिटी के हिसाब
से बनाना है आपको लगता है वो हाई कैटेगरी
की है तो हाई बना उसका सीवीएस स्कोर देख
लीजिएगा सीवीएस स्कोर जो भी आप पर्टिकुलर
वने बिलिटी के देख रहे हैं उसके अकॉर्डिंग
आप हाई क्रिटिकल जो भी है वो बता सकते हैं
उसके बाद है इंपॉर्टेंट है टैग्स तो ये
टैग्स क्यों इंपॉर्टेंट है मैं आपको बता
देता हूं यहां पे जो आप टैग्स लिखे
जैसे आप इसमें लिखा हुआ कॉन्फिडो जर टैग
राइट तो यानी कि इन टैग्स को अगर कोई
न्यूक्लि आई के कमांड में यूज कर रहा है
इट मींस की वह पर्टिकुलर टारगेट पर यह
टेंप्लेट ऑटोमेटिक एग्जीक्यूट हो जाएगी
इवन वीी आर नॉट असाइनिंग वी आर नॉट यूजिंग
दिस टेंप्लेट ठीक है हम टेंप्लेट को यूज
नहीं भी कर रहे इसका मतलब क्या है मैं य
पर आपको दिखा देता हूं मैं एक काम करता
हूं लेट्स गो टू दिस
वन यहां पे
कोई वेबसाइट मिल जाती है तो कोई भी मिल
जागी तो हम व कर लेंगे इस देख लेंगे एक
बार डिंग य से कर सकते
हैं चलिए बिग य यह वाली वेबसाइट कर लेते
हैं बिग हेलो वाली ठीक है तो वी आर गोइंग
टू डू यहां पर
बिग हेलो ठीक है सॉरी हां ये वाली ये
वेबसाइट को हम मान लो अभी रख लेते हैं
टारगेट प बिगड आ ठीक है यह वेबसाइट है
यहां पे दिस वेबसाइट इज दिस नीचे कर लेते
हैं यह एक ई-कॉमर्स वेबसाइट
है शॉप लोकेटर क्या
है
ओके रिटर्न ठीक है यहां पे इनका
डिस्क्लोजर पॉलिसी है हां तो यहां
डिस्क्लोजर पॉलिसी है इनका अब यहां पे
सिंपल लिखा हुआ है रिस्पांसिबल डिस्क्लोजर
पॉलिसी सी वी कांस्टेंटली स्ट्राइव टू मेक
आवर सिस्टम सेफ फॉर आवर कस्टमर टू यूज़
हाउ एवर इफ इन दिस केस सेंसिटिव अ
सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चर और और अ मेंबर ऑफ़
जनरल पब्लिक डिस्कवर्स अ सिक्योरिटी वलने
बिलिटी इन आवर सिस्टम्स तो उनको आप सो @ अ
स @ big.in पे इनको वलने बिलिटी रिपोर्ट
कर सकते हैं तो मान लो चलो मान के चलते
हैं यह हमारा एक टारगेट है बिग h . आ ठीक
है तो hpsbys.in
न्यूक्लि आई एंड देन हम हाइ फन य दे देते
हैं यह टारगेट हमने मेंशन कर दिया उसके
बाद हम हाइन ए हाइन यहां पे टी देके हम
टेंप्लेट मेंशन कर सकते हैं राइट अगर हम
चाहे तो हाइन t देके यहां पे टेंपलेट्स को
मेंशन कर सकते हैं बट हमें क्या यूज करना
है गाइस हमें टैग्स यूज करने हैं तो आपको
यहां पे पता ही होगा हान h देके यहां पे
मैं ग्रेप करूंगा टैग्स को तो यहां पे
आपको दिखेगा कि एक ऑप्शन है यहां हाइन
टैग्स का यानी कि आप टेंपलेट्स टू रन
बेस्ड ऑन टग यानी कि आप टैग्स के बेस पर
टेंप्लेट को रन कर सकते हैं या अगर हम सेम
कमांड यहां पर डालते हैं यहां पर यह वाली
न्यूक्लि आई हाइन यू एंड यहां पर हमने
टारगेट डाला एंड यहां पर हमने हाइन टैग्स
दे दिया टी ए जीी एस टैग्स अब यहां पर हम
जो भी टैग मेंशन करेंगे ना वो टैग के टैग
जिन जिन टेंप्लेट में होंगे जैसे कि यहां
पर हमने टेंप्लेट के अंदर में टैग दिया
राइट यहां पर हमने टेंप्लेट के अंदर में
क्या दिया टैग कॉन्फिन एक्सपोजर तो अगर
हमने यहां पर सिर्फ एक्सपोजर भी लिख दिया
वी आर जस्ट राइटिंग एक्सपोजर ठीक है टैक्स
के अंदर में तो जितने भी ऐसे टेंप्लेट
जिसम ये टैग लिखा होगा टेंप्लेट के अंदर
ये चीज कोड की गई होगी जैसे य पर एक्सपोजर
लिखा है वो टेंप्लेट ऑटोमेटिक एी क्यूट हो
जाएगी इस पर्टिकुलर टारगेट के ऊपर में यह
काम है टैक्स का समझ में आ रहा है
इतना समझ में आ रहा
है यह बता दीजिए एवरीवन गेटिंग समझ में आ
रहा
आपको ये टेंपलेट्स का जो मैं ब्रेक डाउन
कर रहा हूं वो आपको समझ में आ रहा है
कैसे-कैसे मैं बहुत सिंपली समझाने की
कोशिश कर रहा हूं याद रखिएगा आपको मैं
चाहता तो दो मिनट में आपका टेंपलेट्स का
वो खत्म कर सकता था क्योंकि कुछ है नहीं
टेंप्लेट के अंदर में बट मैं आपको वन बाय
वन लाइन बाय लाइन समझा रहा हूं लाइन बाय
लाइन आपको मैं इसलिए बता रहा हूं इतने
डिटेल में बता रहा हूं ताकि आप कल कोई ये
ना बोले कि सर आपका फ्री का बग बाउंट का
क्लास होता है तो उसमें नॉलेज जो है वो
फ्री टाइप ही मिलती है फ्री वाली टाइप
मिलती है नॉट अ पेड टाइप ऐसा आपके मन में
नहीं आना चाहिए एवरीथिंग गिवन हियर आर
टोटली ऑफ टॉप नॉच ठीक है
[संगीत]
तो यहां पे अब जो है आपका टेंप्लेट जो है
यहां पे सिंपल सा ये टेंप्लेट जो है इस
पर्टिकुलर टैग्स के लिए एग्जीक्यूट हो
जाएगा उसके बाद आती है आपकी यहां पे दूसरी
फील्ड रिक्वेस्ट अब बात यह है कि ये जो
रिक्वेस्ट वाली चीज है इसको डिप्रेशिएट कर
दिया गया है इस पर्टिकुलर टैग को
डिफरेंशिएबल को डिप्रेशिएट करके इसके जगह
पे प्रोटोकॉल को मतलब एसटीटीपी लिखा जाता
है अब अगर आप एसटीटीपी प्रोटोकॉल यूज़ कर
रहे हैं डीएनएस यूज़ कर रहे तो प्रोटोकॉल
को यहां पे मेंशन किया जाता है पहले यहां
पे रिक्वेस्ट आती थी राइट तो अब यहां पे
ये एचटीटीपी हो चुका है नए वाली जो अपडेट
आई है ना उसके उसके अंदर में तो यहां पे
हम एचटीटीपी यहां पे लिख दो मान लो उसके
बाद आपको बताना है मेथड मेथड कौन सा यूज
करना है तो न्यूक्लि जो है डिफरेंट काइंस
ऑफ एसटीटीपी मेथड्स को सपोर्ट करती है
जैसे गेट हो गया पोस्ट हो गया पुट हो गया
डिलीट हो गया सब ये सब सपोर्ट करती है तो
यहां पे हम गेट कर रहे हैं क्योंकि हम एक
यूआरएल क्वेरी करने वाले हैं उसके बाद आता
है पाथ कि भैया आप जो रिक्वेस्ट कर रहे हो
वो किस पाथ पे जाने वाला है कहां
रिक्वेस्ट होने वाली है तो इसका सबसे एक
बढ़िया यह जो है डिफाइन करने का वह है
वेरिएबल के थ्रू अब भाई वेरिएबल के थ्रू
कैसे डिफाइन करते हैं तो इसमें जो है आप
वेरिएबल एक खुद का क्रिएट कर सकते हैं
इसके अंदर में ये ब्यूटी है इसकी न्यूक्लि
आई की आई विल से तो आपको सिंपली ना आपको
सिंपली क्या करना है यहां पे वेरिएबल बेस
यूआरएल ये हमने एक वेरिएबल को क्रिएट कर
लिया राइट अब यहां पे हमने क्या किया यह
तो बेस यूआरएल हो गया अब यहां पे हमने
स्लैश देक और जो भी पाथ है जैसे एसटी पास
पास
डब्डीसैक्स
यूआरएल जो है दिस इ दिस विल बी कंसीडर्ड
एज अ वेरिएबल एंड ये बेस यूआरएल पता है
यहां पे क्या आएगा यहां पे आपका
आएगा बेस
यूआरएल इज इक्वल टू टारगेट गिवन इनसाइड
द न्यूक्लि कमांड बाय द
यूजर बाय द यूजर बस यही है और कुछ नहीं
इसका मतलब क्या हुआ अगर आपका टारगेट जो है
अगर आपका टारगेट वो एचटीटीपीएस कॉलन स्ल
स्ल एंड आ टारगेट वाज बिग हेलो था ना हां
बिग हेलो बिग हेलोड आ तो यानी कि यह जो
रिक्वेस्ट जाएगी जो गेट रिक्वेस्ट जाएगी
वो किसको जाएगी एटीपीए कॉलन स् बिग हेलोड
आड एटी पास
डब्ल्यूडीटीटी रिक्वेस्ट जो है इस
पर्टिकुलर यूआरएल प जाएगी एंड देखेगी इस
पर्टिकुलर यूआरएल पे कि यह पर्टिकुलर फाइल
एक्सपोज्ड है फिलहाल हम किसके लिए बना रहे
हैं लेट मी
सी यहां पे आ रहा है डिटेक्ट एक्सपोज एटी
पास ड्डी फाइल्स बस इसके लिए बना रहे है
तो उस पर्टिकुलर यूआरएल पे जाएगी एंड
देखेगी कि ये पर्टिकुलर यूआरएल पे ये जो
फाइल है वो एक्सपोज है पब्लिकली कि नहीं
और इसके अंदर कोई सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन है
कि नहीं
दैट्ची ल सकते हैं जिसको हम मैचस कंडीशंस
बोलते हैं मैचस कंडीशंस में एंड या फिर और
आप यूज कर सकते हैं ठीक है मैचर्स कंडीशंस
में आप एंड या और का यूज कर सकते हैं एंड
का मतलब जितनी भी कंडीशंस से सारी
सेटिस्फाई होंगी तभी आपका जो है वो
पर्टिकुलर एग्जीक्यूशन होगी टेंप्लेट के
अंदर में जो हमने डिफाइन किया है एंड अगर
और लगाते हैं तो कोई भी जैसे जो भी आप एक
दोनों में से कोई भी एक होना चाहिए तो
आपको क्लियर ही होगा बहुत इजी टू
अंडरस्टैंड है तो मैचेस कंडीशंस में यहां
पे एंड पहले यूज हो रही है उसके बाद हम
मैचेस में क्या मैचेस में यूज करने वाले
हैं तो पहले टाइप कौन सा है वर्ड है तो
वर्ड एक टाइप है इसके अंदर में आपके
न्यूक्लियर के अंदर में जिसको मैचेस में
यूज करेंगे वर्ड्स में कौन-कौन से वर्ड्स
होने चाहिए भैया तो वर्ड्स में आपके यहां
पे होने चाहिए एसए आपके होने चाहिए एआर व
आपके होने चाहिए 2 आ ठीक है हैशेज है ये
हैशेज एक तरह से आप बोलिए अभी तो ये हैशेज
को यहां पे क्या कर रहे हैं डिफाइन कर रहे
वर्ड्स के अंदर में कि अगर इसको मैच करते
हैं तो भैया बिल्कुल सही अब यहां पे
कंडीशंस में और लगा दिया यहां पे यहां पे
एंड लगाया एंड में यहां पे एक वर्ड दे
दिया अब यहां पे जब आप एंड दिया ना अपने
मैचेस में तो आप मल्टीपल टाइप यूज कर सकते
हो जैसे आपने टाइप वर्ड में ये दे दिया
ठीक है ऐसे करके आप इसके अलावा और भी कोई
टाइप यूज कर सकते हैं जैसे कि आप बॉडी में
यूज कर सकते हैं पार्ट बॉडी के अंदर पार्ट
आता है वो भी आप यूज कर सकते हैं अब यहां
पे है और एक सेकंड हम अब यहां पे है और
कंडीशन में और में यहां पे फिर आप टाइप
क्या है और स्टेटस कोड अब क्या है स्टेटस
कोड 200 ठीक है तो यहां पे क्या बता रहा
है भैया कि अगर स्टेटस कोड 200 हो तो भी
आपको एग्जीक्यूशन जो है इसको करनी है तो
ये एक पर्टिकुलर क्या हो गया एक टेंप्लेट
हो गया टेंप्लेट का एक फॉर्मेट हो गया
बहुत सिंपल सा हम खुद का भी टेंप्लेट
बनाएंगे अभी देखते देखते रहिए वी विल बी अ
लाइक मेकिंग आवर ओन टेंपलेट्स
ठीक है अब इसका जो है अ मतलब टेंपलेट्स
में बहुत सारी तरह की है यहां पे फजिंग का
है सिंपल लेबिलिटी डिटेक्शन के लिए यूज
में लिया जा सकता है फिर उसके बाद आती है
रिक्वेस्ट वाली चीज जो हमने अभी देखा था
तो रॉ रिक्वेस्ट को भी सपोर्ट करता है अगर
आप देखें तो तो आप एसटीटीपी के अंदर आप
मेंशन कर सकते हैं कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है
राइट तो ये तो आपको समझ में ये बहुत लंबी
चौड़ी पूरी की पूरी वो है आप लाइक ब्लॉग
एक तरह से बोल सकते हैं या पढ़ लीजिएगा
ठीक है दिस इज द सिंपल सा कंप्लीट ब्लॉग
ठीक है अबाउट द कस्टम टेंपलेट्स जो है
होता है ठीक है अब यहां पे एक चीज और
देखते हैं यहां पे जब आप आएंगे यहां पे आप
अलग-अलग तरह की चीजें डीबगिंग डीबगिंग है
आपकी यहां पे डीबगिंग के अला आपका फिर
मैचेस के बारे में बताया गया है कि जो
मैचेस के बारे में हमने जो बात की थी वो
मैचेस तो किस तरीके के मैचेस कितने तरह के
मैचेस यहां पे यूज हो रहे हैं वो सारी
चीजें के लिए अब आपको देखना है कि ये
कितने-कितने तरह की मैचेस टेंप्लेट के
अंदर में या फिर आप यूं कहे कि
एक्सट्रैक्टर्स या ये सब चीज अवेलेबल है
वो आप यहां से देख सकते हैं जैसे कि
टेंपलेट्स में आप आएंगे इस पर्टिकुलर
यूआरएल के अंदर में ये भी प्रोजेक्ट
डिस्कवरी का ऑफिशियल है जो गाइड है दिस इज
द ऑफिशियल गाइड तो यहां पे आप आएंगे तो
यहां पे आप एसटीटीपी प्रोटोकॉल अब ये ये
सारे प्रोटोकॉल्स को एचटीटीपी प्रोटोकॉल
नेटवर्क डीएनएस फाइल जावास्क्रिप्ट ये
सारे प्रोटोकॉल्स को सपोर्ट करता है
मोस्टली एटीटीपी को आप बहुत ज्यादा यूज़
करने वाले हैं तो एचटीटीपी में भी बेसिक
एचटीटीपी एक आता है एक रॉ एचटीटीपी आता है
एचटीटीपी फजिंग एचटीटीपी पेलोड्स एंड
एडवांस एचटीटीपी ये सारे सपोर्ट करता है
ठीक है अब हम रॉ एचटीटीपी की बात करें या
बेसिक एसटीटीपी की बात करें तो बेसिक
एटीपी एसटीटीपी जो है यहां पे इस तरीके से
एसटीटीपी स्टार्ट होता है यहां पे मेथड
आपका मेंशन होता है एंड यहां पे इस तरीके
से मेथड में देख फिर पाथ आप देंगे फिर
रीडायरेक्ट अगर आपको कुछ रीडायरेक्ट वगैरह
करना है तो वो कर देंगे मैक्सिमम
रीडायरेक्ट वगैरह ये सब सेट कर सकते हैं
फिर अब आती है बात यहां पे कि ये तो फिक्स
है आपका मेथड में आपके गेट पोस्ट यहां पे
य ये चीज है रिक्वेस्ट मेथड्स कैन बी गेट
पोस्ट पुट डिलीट ईटीसी डिपेंडिंग ऑन द
नीड्स मतलब जितने भी एचटीटीपी मेथड्स है
आप यूज कर सकते हैं यहां पे अब यहां पे है
पाथ तो भैया पाथ में क्या होता है ना द
नेक्स्ट पार्ट ऑफ द रिक्वेस्ट इज पाथ ऑफ द
रिक्वेस्ट पाथ डायनेमिक वेरिएबल कैन बी
प्लेस इन द पाथ टू मॉडिफाई इट्स बिहेवियर
ऑन रन टाइम मतलब डायनेमिक आप यहां पे जो
वेरिएबल है वो डाल सकते हैं तो जैसे कि
कैसे जैसे कि अगर कोई वेरिएबल स्टार्ट
होता है डबल कली ब्रैकेट से एंड होता है
डबल कली ब्रैकेट से अ तो यह जो है आपका
इसमें वेरिएबल कंसीडर होगा कोई भी ऐसी
टर्म आप डाल रहे इसके अंदर में एंड केस
सेंसिटिव होता है राइट तो अब जो है यहां
पे बेस यूआरएल आप देख रहे हैं यहां पे ये
बेस है दिस विल रिप्लेस ऑन रन टाइम इन द
रिक्वेस्ट बाय द इनपुट यूआरएल एज
स्पेसिफाइड इन द टारगेट फाइल ये यहां पे
बेस यूआरएल का मतलब हो गया उसी तरह रूट
यूआरएल दिस विल रिप्लेस ऑन रन टाइम इन द
रिक्वेस्ट बाय द रूट यूआरएल एज स्पेसिफाइड
इन द टारगेट यू तो रूट यूआरएल के लिए
होस्ट नेम के लिए आप इस तरीके से कर सकते
हैं होस्ट के लिए पोर्ट के लिए पाथ के लिए
ये पाथ वाली फाइल के लिए स्कीमों के लिए
ये सारी चीजें आप यहां पे कर सकते हैं
राइट तो यहां पे वेरिएबल का पूरा यहां पे
दिया हुआ है कि बेस यूआरएल में कैसे ये
पूरा यूआरएल है रूट यूआरएल में आपका ये
पर्टिकुलर बेस यूआरएल मतलब कि कंप्लीट जो
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
कौन सा है ठीक है ये चीजें कर सकते हैं
इसके बाद जो आता है आपका गाइस वो आता है
हेडर्स आप हेडर्स भी मेंशन कर सकते हैं
राइट तो यहां पे हेडर्स कैन आल्सो बी स्ड
टू बी सेंट अलोंग विद द रिक्वेस्ट मतलब आप
हेडर्स को चाहे तो रिक्वेस्ट के साथ भेजना
चाहे कोई भी कस्टम हेडर भेजना चाहते हैं
खुद से कुछ लिख के भेजना चाहते हैं वो भी
आप यहां पे सिंपली यहां पे बता सकते हैं
ठीक है तो इस तरीके से आप हेडर लगा सकते
हैं अब आती है बॉडी तो बॉडी स्पेस बॉडी टू
बी सेंट अलोंग विद द रिक्वेस्ट तो बॉडी
में जो रिक्वेस्ट के साथ जाएगी वो बॉडी के
साथ आप डिफाइन करेंगे यहां पे बताएंगे फिर
यहां पे सेशन आती है सेशन में आप यहां पे
सिंपल यहां पे डिसेबल कुकी ट्रू कर सकते
हैं मतलब कुकी को इनेबल डिसेबल और सेशन से
रिलेटेड सारी चीज यहां पे आप बता सकते हैं
अब यहां पे रिक्वेस्ट कंडीशंस है तो
रिक्वेस्ट कंडीशंस के अंदर में स्टेटस
कोड्स अ ये सारी जो एट्रिल होती है वो
अट्रीब्ज कर सकते हैं एंड जैसे कि अब यहां
पे मैचेस के अंदर में यूज हो रहा है टाइप
डीएसएल डीएसएल स्टेटस कोड व 404 ऐसे
स्टेटस कोड टू यहां पे 200 हो गया मतलब एक
स्टेटस कोड 404 हो फिर एंड स्टेटस कोड टू
200 भी हो कंटेंस बॉडी टू बॉडी सीक्रेट
स्ट्रिंग इस तरीके से आप एक साथ यूज कर
सकते हैं इसको कंप्लीट की तरह ठीक है ये
तो आपको समझ में आ गया होगा अब ये प्रॉपर
एक एसटीटीपी का टेंप्लेट का एग्जांपल है
सिंपल सा एसटीटीपी टेंप्लेट एग्जांपल है
नथिंग एल्स ये मैंने ऑलरेडी आपको ऑलरेडी
बता दिया है ऑलरेडी डिफाइन कर दिया है
समझा दिया है कि किस तरीके से ये एचटीटीपी
टेंप्लेट जो होती है या किस तरीके से
एचटीटीपी टेंप्लेट ये दिखता है तो बस ये
वही चीज है सेम चीज है नथिंग डिफरेंट हियर
इसको जब हम रियल टाइम में एग्जीक्यूट
करेंगे एंड इसको जब हम खुद से जब क्रिएट
करेंगे ना बनाएंगे तो ज्यादा आपको समझ में
आएगा े समझ में तो आ रहा है ना सबको दिमाग
कितने लोगों के दिमाग के ऊपर से जा रहा है
य बता
दीजिए बता
दीजिए एसएस यूएफ के बारे में बताना ठीक है
बता दूंगा एसस यूफ कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
है दिमाग के ऊपर से भी जा रहा है किसी के
या सबको समझ में आ रहा
है ठीक है बहुत कम लोग जवाब दे रहे हैं
सभी लोग जवाब दीजिए सभी लोग प्लीज जवाब
दीजिए एवरी बडी जवाब दीजिए मैं पानी लेकर
आ जाता
हूं ओ मैंने पानी तो
मैंने पानी तो यहीं पे रखी हुई है मैं
पानी लेने कहां चला
गया
ओके ओके ठीक है तो सभी को समझ में आ रही
है यह अच्छी बात है चलिए ट्स
ग्रेट हम
ठीक
है ओके गॉट इट ठीक है समझ में आ गया चलिए
अब यहां पे यह तो आपको समझ में आ गया होगा
एसटीडीपी मेथड और ये सब लगाते हैं बेस ये
सब लगाते हैं ठीक है उसी तरीके से यहां पे
आप र एसटीटीपी प आएंगे तो रॉ एसटीटीपी की
चीजें यहां पे आपको समझ में आएंगी कि रॉ
के अंदर में आप बेसिकली पूरा का पूरा पूरा
का पूरा एक हेडर को
कॉन्फिन हेडर जो होती है ना आपके बब शूट
में जैसे आप देखते हैं रिक्वेस्ट हैडर को
तो आप पूरी हर चीज यहां पर मेंशन कर सकते
हैं र एडीपी के अंदर में यह एक खूबी है
न्यूक्लि टेंप्लेट
की ठीक दिस खूबी यू कैन से
राइट लेट हो गया सर थोड़ रिकप कर दो रिकप
नहीं होती आपको रिकॉर्डिंग देखनी पड़ेगी
रिकप कभी नहीं
होती ठीक है
मुझे कुछ समझ नहीं आया कोई बात नहीं समझ
में आ जाएगा कोई बात नहीं समझ में आ जाएगा
इनको इनको चल टाटा बावे कर देते
हैं मस्ती ज्यादा रही है
ना थोड़ा-थोड़ा समझ आ रहा है सर
थोड़ा-थोड़ा ठीक है देखो अभी जो कस्टम
टेंपलेट्स की बात है तो यहां पे
थोड़ा-थोड़ा अगर आपको समझ में आ रहा है तो
ये बहुत अच्छी बात है अगर आपको थोड़ा भी
समझ में आ रहा है तो थोड़ी प्रैक्टिस की
जरूरत है प्रैक्टिस जब करेंगे तो आप
टेंपलेट्स बना पाएंगे न्यूक्लि के बहुत
इजी टू मेक है एंड एक बार आप समझ गए ना तो
आप फटाफट फटाफट बना लेंगे कोई बड़ी बात
नहीं है राइट इतना आपको समझ में आना चाहिए
एक बार सीख लिया फट फट फट फट फट फट
दैट्ची र एसटीटीपी वाले को रॉ एसटीटीपी
में किस तरीके से काम करता है एसटीटीपी
फजिंग कैसे काम करता है ये सारी चीजें ठीक
है अब यहां पे हम सिंपल से टेंप्लेट को एक
डिजाइन करने वाले हैं एक कस्टम टेंप्लेट
को हम डिजाइन करने वाले हैं राइट वी विल
ट्राई टू डिजाइन अ कस्टम टेंप्लेट चलिए
उसके पहले हम यहां पे एक चीज देखते हैं एक
हम एक चीज को हम यूज करना सीखते हैं समझते
हैं ठीक है एक चीज को समझते हैं जैसे मान
लो मैं न्यूक्लि के न्यूक्लि टूल को यूज
चला रहा हूं न्यूक्लि टूल हाइन किया ठीक
है अब मैं इसको चलाने वाला हूं अब यहां पे
मैं एक नया टर्मिनल ओपन कर लेता हूं एंड
मैं न्यूक्लि लिखता हूं यहां पे हाइन य दे
देता हूं यहां पे जो हमारा टारगेट है तो
टारगेट हमारा क्या है ये वाली टारगेट है
कौन सी टारगेट थी
यार बिग हेलो करके टारगेट था ना भाई कौन
सी थी
[संगीत]
बिग हेलोड आ हा ठीक है बिग हेलोड आ टारगेट
है हमारा तो हमने यहां पर क्या किया
एसटीपीएस
कॉलन
बिग बिग हेलो डॉट आयन हमने ये टारगेट
मेंशन कर दिया ठीक है अब हम यहां पर
सिंपली अगर एक हान t दे देते हैं
टेंपलेट्स का टेंप्लेट के लिए दे दिया
हमने नटी और अब हम यहां पर ना टेंप्लेट को
एक चूज कर लेते हैं तो हम चलो एक्सपोजर
वाला टेंप्लेट चूज कर लेते चलिए
एटीटीपी के अंदर
आएगा
एक्सपोजर एक्सपोजर अब हम इस टेंपलेट को
मान लो चलाना चाहते हैं इस पर्टिकुलर
टारगेट प तो हमने यहां पर टारगेट पर चलाया
लेटस सी व्ट इ हैपनिंग देखते हैं टेंपलेट
क्लस्टर्ड ना लेट्स वेट फॉर द रिजल्ट
[संगीत]
यहां पर आप देख लीजिएगा करंट न्यूक्लि
वर्जन आपका लेटेस्ट है एंड करंट न्यूक्लि
टेंपलेट्स आपका यहां पे लेटेस्ट है ठीक है
ओके तो यहां पे एक हमें क्रेडेंशियल से
डिस्क्लोजर मिला है क्या बात है वी गट अ
क्रेडेंशियल डिस्क्लोजर यहां पे जहां पे
एक एक्सेस टोकन मिला है इस पर्टिकुलर
वेबसाइट के अंदर में यह तो अच्छी चीज
है यह बड़ी चीज है यह बढ़िया चीज है यह तो
हमें यहां पे कुछ एक रिजल्ट मिला राइट
हमें यहां पे यहां पे एक फाइनल रिजल्ट
हमें मिल चुका है राइट अब हम यहां पे ना
एक चीज और करेंगे व्हाट वी विल डू एक चीज
हम क्या करेंगे हमने सेम चीज की यहां पे
हम न्यूक्लि टेंपलेट्स की एसटीटीपी पूरी
एसटीटीपी को ही चला देते हैं नॉट जस्ट
एक्सपोजर पूरे एचटीटीपी के अंदर जितने भी
आपके टेंपलेट्स हैं वह सबको यहां पर रन कर
देते हैं वी आर रनिंग एवरी पर्टिकुलर
टेंपलेट्स ले देखते हैं कितने टट्स लोड
हुए हैं
7932 7932 साइन टेंप्लेट जो है इसमें लोड
हुए हैं एंड ये बहुत ही यूज हो गए
टेंपलेट्स को क्लस्टर्ड किया गया है यहां
पे एंड देन ये एग्जीक्यूट हो रही
है सो लेट्स सी व्हाट इज
हैपनिंग कुछ चीज दिखाऊंगा मैं आपको एंड
देन हम कस्टम टेंपलेट्स को क्रिएट करेंगे
अपनी
एक हम यहां पे रेड में वार्निंग है आप देख
सकते हैं फाउंड टू टेंपलेट्स विथ रन टाइम
एरर यूज हाइन वैलिडेट फ्लैग फॉर फदर
एग्जामिनेशन मतलब कोई रन टाइम एरर आई है
इनमें तो इन्होंने वार्निंग दे दी
है इसलिए कभी भी सारे टेंपलेट्स को आपको
यूज नहीं करने हैं पहले ही मैं आपको बता
देता हूं यू डोंट हैव टू यूज एवरी
टेंप्लेट इसका एक तरीका भी बताता हूं कि
आप किस तरीके से यूज कर पाएंगे उसको बहुत
इंपोर्टेंट चीज है बहुत इंपोर्टेंट तरीका
है आप इसको
देखिएगा अभी तक कुछ हमें मिला नहीं है वी
हैव नॉट फाउंड एनीथिंग टिल नाउ
लेट सी व्ट इ हैपनिंग व्ट इ द रिजल्ट ट व
आर गेटिंग उससे मुझे मतलब है मैं आपको
उसके थ्रू कुछ
दिखाऊंगा तो हमें यहां पर कुछ
मिला मिसिंग एसआर आई ठीक है एसटीडीपी फ
इंफॉर्मेशन है वफ डिटेक्शन हुई यहां पर
इंफॉर्मेशन
क्लाउड फ्लेयर ठीक है एंज जनरिक
बिघल
पे य गट सम रिजल्ट्स राइट वल गेट मोर ऑफ द
रिजल्ट्स और जब भी आपको ऐसी कोई रिजल्ट
मिले और यहां पे जब आपको जेएस फाइल्स मिले
ना जेएस फाइल तो जेएस रिकॉर्न जरूर करना
मत भूलिए
जेएस रिकन इज वेरी वेरी इंपॉर्टेंट
जावास्क्रिप्ट रिकन उसके अंदर हम आपको
बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें मिल सकती है जैसे
जेएस फाइल है यहां तो इसके अंदर में बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग कीवर्ड्स के लिए लाइक
पास वर्ड हो गया या आपका एपीआई हो गई यहां
पर अब देखो यहां प एपीआई ट्रैकिंग कितने
मैचेस हो गए हैं टू मैचेस है तो यहां पर
एपीआई हो गया आपका देन आपका यहां
पे एक्सेस टोकन हो गई इस तरीके की चीज जो
कीवर्ड्स की चीजें हैं यहां पे आपको
जावास्क्रिप्ट के अंदर में बहुत सारी
चीजें मिल जाती हैं जो आपके लिए
बेनिफिशियल हो सकती है यहां पे एक फॉर्म
डिटेक्शन हुआ यहां पे मिसिंग सिक्योरिटी
हेडर्स ठीक है यहां पे रेफरल पॉलिसी
क्लियर साइड डाटा परमिशन पॉलिसी यहां पे
क्रॉस ओरिजिन एंबेड पॉलिसी ये सब कुछ जो
हेडर्स हैं वो मिसिंग है बट खैर ये सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन ही है
robot.txt न को कैंसिल कर दिया है तो आपकी
एक फाइल क्रिएट हो जाती है रिज्यूम फाइल
जिसको बोलते हैं जिसका फॉर्मेट लास्ट में
जो एक्सटेंशन होता है सीएफजी होता है तो
आप इस फाइल के थ्रू इस पर्टिकुलर स्कैन को
वापस से रिज्यूम कर सकते हैं ये कैसे कर
सकते हैं इसके लिए एक राइफ रिज्यूम टैग है
देखो यहां पे हाइन रिज्यूम ये वाली तो
स्कैन यूजिंग रिजूम . सीएजी दैट्ची जैसे
यानी कि आपको न्यूक्लि आपको न्यूक्लि चला
देना है यहां पे सिंपल सा यहां पे एंड
आपको क्या करना है सिंपल हाइन रिज्यूम ऐसे
करके एंड आपको जो फाइल है वह फाइल यहां पे
मेंशन कर देनी है हमने यहां प मेंशन किया
उसके बाद जो आपका पर्टिकुलर जो लास्ट
सेव्ड आपका स्कैन था जो आप कर रहे थे वह
सेम स्कैन जो है यहां पर स्टार्ट हो जाएगा
आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे कि ऑलरेडी यहां
पे स्कैन हो चुका है एंड यहां पे मतलब वो
जी जो चीज है वो स्टार्ट हो जाएगी एंड
आपका काम करना शुरू कर देगा
राइट इस तरीके से आप स्कैन मतलब रिज्यूम
कर सकते हैं ठीक है तो यहां पे आप इसको
रिज्यूम का यूज कर सकते हैं अब यहां पे एक
चीज और मैं आपको बता देता हूं जैसे मान लो
आपने कोई न्यूक्लि आई का कमांड चलाया ठीक
है आपने कोई न्यूक्लि का ये कमांड चला है
आपको रिजल्ट में कुछ खास नहीं मिल रहा या
कोई ब्लॉकिंग आ रही है जैसे कि एक बंदा
बोल रहा था अभी एक स्टूडेंट बोल रहा था कि
सर मैं जब भी चलाता हूं क्या होता है कि
मैं सारे टेंपलेट्स यूज़ कर लि मुझे
विनेबिलिटी नहीं मिल रही है तो पहली बात
तो आपको सारे टेंप्लेट यूज नहीं करने अगर
यूज़ करने भी है तो आपको रेट लिमिट का यूज
करते हुए करना है जैसे मैं मान लो यहां पे
बिग हेलोड आ पे यहां पे सारे टेंपलेट्स को
यूज कर रहा हू तो जब मैं सारे टेंप्लेट को
यूज करूंगा सिंपल इसको डिफाइन करके तो यह
हो सकता है पॉसिबल है कि यहां पे किसी तरह
की ब्लॉकिंग आ जाए जो फायरवॉल है वो ब्लॉक
कर दे आपके रिक्वेस्ट को तो यहां पे आपको
रेट लिमिटिंग ऑप्शन का यूज करना पड़ेगा जो
आपको इसके अंदर में ऑलरेडी दी गई है जब आप
नीचे की तरफ आएंगे हेल फाइल
में यहां प आपको रेट लिमिट दिखेगी रेट
लिमिट में हान आरएल आपको मिलेगा मैक्सिमम
नंबर ऑफ रिक्वेस्ट टू सेंड पर सेकंड
डिफॉल्ट 150 रिक्वेस्ट है पता है ये बहुत
बड़ी रिक्वेस्ट बहुत बड़ा नंबर होता है तो
न आरएल जो है 150 को मैं 25 कर दूंगा जस्ट
25 ठीक है ये हमने कर दिया अब आ जाओ इधर
रेट लिमिट ड्यूरेशन वैल्यूज की जरूरत नहीं
है आरएम रेट लिमिट मिनट लिमिट जरूरत नहीं
है बीएस हां ये एक इंपॉर्टेंट है बल्क
साइज इंटी जर में मैक्सिमम नंबर ऑफ
होस्ट्स टू बी एनालाइज्ड इन पैरेलल पर
टेंप्लेट डिफॉल्ट 25 है तो भाई इतने नहीं
करने मुझे तो माइ मैंने भाई माइनस बीएस
पाच कर दिया मैं पांच ही रखूंगा जस्ट फाइव
तो ये हमने कर दिया उसके बाद कं करेंसी
इंजर मैक्सिमम नंबर ऑफ टेंपलेट्स टू बी
एग्जीक्यूटेड इन पैरेलल तो यहां पे हाइन
सी करके पैरेलल में 25 यहां पे दे रखा है
इन्होंने इसको भी हम यहां पे कम कर देंगे
तो यहां पे हाइन सी करके यहां पे 10 कर
देते हैं पांच तो नहीं करेंगे 10 कर देते
हैं ठीक है उसके बाद हैडलेस के लिए अभी
जरूरत है नहीं फिलहाल के लिए बस इतना हम
कर देते हैं यह भी काफी ज्यादा हो जाता है
आपके लिए काफी अच्छी खासी डेट लिमिट आपने
लगा दी है अब जब आप इसको एग्जीक्यूट
करेंगे तो यहां पे डिटेक्शन के चांसेस कम
होंगे बहुत कम होंगे फेलियर के चांसेस कम
होंगे एंड आपको रिजल्ट जो है वो अच्छा
खासा मिलेगा अब इसके रिजल्ट देने में लेट
हो सकता है लेट थोड़ी हो सकती है ऐसा कि
नहीं कि तुरंत आपको रिजल्ट मिल जाएगा
क्योंकि आपने रेट लिमिट लगा दिया है तो
थोड़ा स्लो प्रोसेस होगा बट स्टिल ये आपको
बेटर रिजल्ट प्रोवाइड करेगा एंड ब्लॉकिंग
के चांस जो है ना वो बहुत कम हो
जाएंगे ठीक है न्यूक्लि आई टेंपलेट्स को
कम नहीं करता है वो बस क्लस्टरिंग करता है
टेंप्लेट को जैसे आप एक रिक्वेस्ट भेज
भेजना चाहते हो ना तो वो एक रिक्वेस्ट जो
है वही जाएगी व जैसे आपने मान लो कि कोई
रिक्वेस्ट भेजा तो एक रिक्वेस्ट को
मल्टीपल उस तरीके से चैनल से होते हुए
रिक्वेस्ट को भेजेगा और उसके जो रिस्पांस
है उसको मल्टीपल टेंप्लेट एनालाइज कर
रिक्वेस्ट तो एक ही जाएगी बट उसको एनालाइज
मल्टीपल टेंपलेट्स करेंगे उसके जो
रिस्पांस है तो इस तरीके से क्या होता है
रिक्वेस्ट कम जाते है जैसे मान लो आपने
यहां पर देखो ना यहां पे जैसे यहां
पे यहां पे टेंप्लेट
क्लस्टर 15 98 को यहां पे क्लस्टर गया
रिड्यूस्ड 1502 रिक्वेस्ट को 1502 को यहां
पे रिड्यूस कर दिया गया इसने तो यहां पे
अगर आपने जैसे 10 रिक्वेस्ट भेजे हैं तो
यहां पे ये क्या करेगा एक रिक्वेस्ट
भेजेगा उसके रिस्पांस को 10 अलग-अलग
टेंप्लेट से एनालाइज करवाएगा तो ये एक
बेनिफिट है टेंप्लेट क्लस्टरिंग का
न्यूक्लि आई के अंदर में तो इस वजह से
न्यूक्लि आई ये काम करता है एंड दिस इज
एक्चुअली वेरी गुड ठीक है तो यहां पे ये
टेस्टिंग चल रही है क्योंकि हमने अ रेड
लिमिट लगा दिया है हमने बल्क साइज को कम
किया है हमने कं करेंसी कम की है सब कम
करके यहां पे किया है तो इसमें थोड़ा सा
समय लग जाएगा बट आपको जो रिजल्ट है वो
काफी अच्छा मिलेगा आप जो बोल रहे हैं कि
मुझे वलने बिलिटी नहीं मिलती है वो इसकी
वजह से भी नहीं मिलेगी जब आप रेट लिमिट को
सही से यूज नहीं करेंगे एंड आपको कभी भी
सारे टेंप्लेट न्यूक्लि को यूज नहीं करने
कई सारे फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स भी आपको मिलके
देंगे याद रखिएगा कि न्यूक्लि के अंदर
आपको हमेशा 100% जेनुइन ही अ रिजल्ट नहीं
मिलेंगे फाल्स पॉजिटिव्स भी मिलते हैं तो
फाल्स पॉजिटिव्स को अगर आपको अवॉइड करना
है तो आप कम टेंपलेट्स का एंड एकदम कं
साइज टू द पॉइंट टेंप्लेट का यूज कीजिए जो
चीज आप चाहते हैं खोजना करना आप उसी को
यूज कीजिए उसी को ट्राई कीजिए वो ज्यादा
बेटर होगा ठीक
है चलिए तो यह तो अपना काम ये तो अपना काम
कर रहा है अब इसको मैं एक नया टाइम में
आता हूं इसको चलने देते हैं इस प्रोसेस को
इसमें थोड़ा सा टाइम लगेगा ये इसकी हेल्प
फाइल है न्यूक्लि की एंड अब हम कस्टम
न्यूक्लि आई टेंप्लेट के ऊपर में थोड़ा सा
काम कर लेते
हैं जैसा कि मैंने आप सबको बताया कि कस्टम
न्यूक्लि आई टेंप्लेट जो है उसकी एक
फॉर्मेट
उस फॉर्मेट के थ्रू आप कस्टम न्यूक्लि
टेंप्लेट अपना लिख सकते हैं तो उसका
एक्सटेंशन वाई एमएल याल होगा हमेशा से जो
भी आप कस्टम न्यूक्लियर टेंप्लेट लिखेंगे
उसका हमेशा से वा एमएल होगा वाई ए एमएल
एक्सटेंशन होगा तो आपको सिंपल एक टेक्स्ट
एडिटर ओपन करना है ए उसमें आपको कोई भी एक
नाम दे देना है तो मैं एक क्या करता हूं
मैं यहां
पर जीएचडीबी पर चलता हूं जीएचडीबी
एंड यहां पर चलते हैं एंड मैं यहां पर
कॉन्फिन का एक बनाता हूं यहां पर जैसे कि
य
gojav.xyz वो पब्लिकली एक्सेसिबल है कि
नहीं और उसके अंदर कोई सेंसिटिव
इंफॉर्मेशन है कि नहीं ये भी आप चेक कर
सकते हैं या तो आप सीधा ये भी कर सकते हैं
कि पब्लिकली अवेलेबल है एक्सेसिबल है कि
नहीं है ठीक है तो ये वाली चीज हम करते
हैं
चलिए कॉन्ग जन को करते हैं ठीक है तो अब
जो है हम एक फाइल क्रिएट करेंगे सिंपल
व्हाट वी विल डू यहां पे आपको रिजल्ट
आएंगे धीरे-धीरे वी विल बी क्रिएटिंग अ
फाइल तो हम फाइल विम के थ्रू ही करेंगे
यहां पे ननो आप यूज कर सकते हैं विम जो भी
आप चाहे विम यहां पे करते हैं
कस्टम जेसन
वा ए ये हमने एक फाइल का नाम दे
दिया कस्टम जसन या कॉन्फिन लिख
दो कॉन्फिन डवाल य हमने दिया य पर एंटर कर
दिया हम विम के अंदर में आ गए अब हमें
सबसे पहले सबसे पहले क्या लिखनी है हमें
यहां पर मुझे बताइए सबसे पहले क्या लिखना
है यहां पर ऊपर में क्या देंगे मुझे बताइए
आप लोग बताइए
बताइए आम
सींग ठीक है मोहम्मद हसन राजा खान आई विल
ट्राई बताइए पहले क्या लिखेंगे बहुत कम
लोग रिप्लाई कर रहे हैं यार एक्टिव नहीं
हो तुम लोग मतलब मेरे से ज्यादा एक्टिव
रहना चाहिए आप बट आप ही लेस एक्टिव है आप
लोग भी बहुत लेस एक्टिव हो यार मानना
पड़ेगा बहुत देखो दो लोगों का रिप्लाई आया
सबसे पहले क्या लिखेंगे हम सबसे पहला
कीवर्ड क्या
होगा यहां पर सबसे अब देखो पूछ रहा है कि
क्या सर यहां हम टेंप्लेट कन्फ हम एक
कस्टम टेंप्लेट बना रहे हैं जिसका हमने
नाम दिया है क्या नाम दिया है कॉफिट
कॉन्फिन डट वा एल अब यहां पर हमें कस्टम
टेंप्लेट का जो हमारा जो पूरा का पूरा
टेंप्लेट का हमने जब देखा था न्यूक्लि के
टेंपलेट्स को एग्जांपल के तौर पर तो हमने
जो देखा था उसके हिसाब से सबसे पहले हमें
क्या यहां पर लिखना
है
सैलेश यह बॉय ठीक है और कोई बोलो सलेश
बारबार मत करो प्लीज
डोंट स्पैम
बिल्कुल तो सबसे पहले जो है हम यहां पर
आईडी मेंशन करेंगे आईडी यहां पर हमने आईडी
मेंशन किया अब हमने दे दिया य पर
कॉन्फिन यहां पर हमने दे दिया जसन यह हमने
आईडी लिख दिया कॉन्फिन इस तरीके से हमने
दे दिया यहां प अब यहां पे आप कुछ भी दे
सकते हो जैसे कॉन्फिन ऐसे दिया
कॉन्फिन फाइल्स ऐसे दे दिया कुछ भी आईडी
में आप कुछ भी दे दो डजन मैटर य हमने दे
दिया उसके बाद अब हमें यहां पर क्या करना
है अब हमें यहां पर इंफो देनी है इंफो तो
भैया अब इंफो के अंदर क्या-क्या चीजें
आएंगी वह सारी चीजें आपको डाल देनी है तो
इंफो में यहां पे आएगा पहले तो नेम इसका
नाम आप क्या देना चाहते हैं व्हाट नेम यू
वांट टू गिव इट तो हम यहां पे दे देते हैं
एक्सपोज्ड
अ
जेसन
कॉन्फिन टारगेट यह हमने इसका नाम दे दिया
यह हमने इसका नाम दे दिया अब यहां पे हम
मेंशन करेंगे ऑथर को तो ऑथर कौन सा है
भैया ऑथर का आप नाम दे दीजिए जो भी आप ऑथर
है तो मैं अपना नाम मान लो दे देता हूं
नितेश ये कि मैं ऑथर हूं ठीक है यहां पे
आपने नाम दे दिया उसके बाद अब आप क्या आती
है अब आपको यहां पे मेंशन करना है कि इसकी
सीवियरिंग क्या होगी व्हाट इज द सीवियरिंग
तो मैं यहां पे सीवियरिंग तो यहां पे
सीवियरिंग मैंने यहां पे अ सीवियरिंग में
आप मतलब देख लो इसका हाई कर दो आप इसका
सीवियरिंग क्या कि आपने हाई कर दिया ठीक
है अब यहां पे इसके अलावा आप डिस्क्रिप्शन
भी दे सकते हो अगर चाहते हो डिस्क्रिप्शन
देना तो दे दो यहां पर डिस्क्रिप्शन
डिस्क्रिप्शन में क्या दोगे भैया
कि चेक इफ द टारगेट
हैज
कॉन्फिन
फाइल
पब्लिकली एक्सपोज एंड
कंटेंस सेंसिटिव
इंफोज हमने दे दिया ट्स इट इतना आप कर
सकते कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है य पर कन्फ ज या
फिर कैसे भी देना जैसे देना आप दे सकते हो
डिस्क्रिप्शन आपने य लिख लिया अब यहां पर
आप चाहे तो रेफरेंस लिख सकते हो ना चाहे
तो ना लिखो आपकी मर्जी है जैसे आप रेफरेंस
दे दे रहे हो तो यहां पर रेफरेंस हमने
दिया अब यहां आप चाहे तो रेफरेंस दे दो
नहीं चाहते हो रेफरेंस मत दो तो रेफरेंस
का एक देने का तरीका है मैं फिर भी बता
देता हूं य जैसे मान
लो यहां
पे कन्फ
जेसन यहां पर हमने दिया यहां पे चलो यह
मान लो कनेटिक्स का ये एक यूआरएल है मान
लो मैं इसको ए रेफरेंस देना चाहता हूं कि
भया इसको एज अ रेफरेंस ले लो ठीक है इसके
बारे में यहां प बताया गया है तो इसको एज
रेफरेंस ले लो तो मैं यहां पे डालूंगा
यहां पे सिंपल सा यहां प हमने रेफरेंस डाल
दिया अब रेफरेंस को जब आप एंटर करोगे तो
इसके अंदर में एक चीज क्या दोगे इस तरीके
से यहां प डैश आप लगाओगे रेफरेंस के अंदर
में क्या लगाओगे डैश लगाओगे यहां पे एंड
देन आप यहां पर यूआरएल डिफाइन करोगे जो
आपका यूआरएल है पर्टिकुलर जो आप यूआरएल
रेफरेंस के तौर प यहां प देना चाहते हैं
वो यहां प डिफाइन कर देंगे ठीक है ये समझ
में अब यहां प हमें टैग्स देना है तो यहां
पे हम टैग्स दे
दो अब टैक्स में क्या जो जो टैक्स देना
चाहते हो दे दो जैसे
कि
कॉन्फिन
कॉफिक्स दे सकते हो जो भी आप टैग देना
चाहो यू कैन जस्ट गिव इट कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है ठीक है यहां पे कॉन्फिडे दिया
यहां पे जेसन कॉन्फिडे दी फिर यहां पे
सेंसिटिव डाटा यहां पे दे दिया ऐसे करके
आप जो भी टैक्स देना चाहते हो आप टैक्स
यहां पे दे सकते हो अब इसके बाद जो है
आपको यहां बतानी है प्रोटोकॉल कौन सी
प्रोटोकॉल आप यूज़ करना चाहते हैं तो मैं
यहां पे एसटीटीपी प्रोटोकॉल यूज़ करना
चाहता हूं तो हमने एसटीटीपी दे दिया अब
एसटीटीपी प्रोटोकॉल के अंदर में आप मेथड
कौन सा यूज़ करेंगे तो मैं यहां पे मेथड
यहां पे मेंशन करूंगा एंड मेथड को यहां पे
गेट दे दूंगा आप जो मेथड यूज़ करना चाहे
आप वही मेथड यूज़ कीजिएगा जो मेथड आपको
जरूरी है वही जरूरी नहीं है कि आप गेट
मेथड यूज़ करेंगे जरूरी नहीं है कि आप
पोस्ट यूज़ करेंगे जो मेथड आपको जब जरूरत
है एटीटीपी मेथड की आप यहां पे यूज कर
लेंगे अब यहां पे जो सबसे इंटरेस्टिंग चीज
आती है वो आती है एंड दैट इज
पाथ पाथ को यहां पे आपको डिफाइन करना है
पाथ को अब पाथ के अंदर की चीजों को आपको
डिफाइन करना है तो जब भी किसी अंदर की चीज
को डिफाइन करेंगे तो आप डैश से करेंगे तो
यहां पे आपके यहां पे डैश आपने एरिया पाथ
के अंदर में और यहां पे स्पेस डस के बाद
आपको स्पेस दे देना है अब पाथ के अंदर में
हमें क्या डिफाइन करना है तो हमें वो पूरा
का पूरा पाथ चाहिए ना भाई वी वांट होल पाथ
राइट कि वो पूरा पाथ आ जाए हमारे पास तो
उस पाथ को हम डबल कोट के अंदर में यहां पे
एंटर करना शुरू करेंगे सबसे पहले एक
वेरिएबल असाइन करेंगे जैसा कि मैंने आपको
पहले बोला था आई ऑलरेडी टोल्ड यू कि
वेरिएबल वीी विल असाइन अब वो वेरिएबल
असाइन करने के लिए हम यहां पे क्योंकि
यूआरएल ले रहे हैं एज अ इनपुट फ्रॉम द
यूजर इट सेल्फ तो हम यहां पे क्या यूज़
करने वाले
हम यहां पे यूज करने वाले हैं बेस यूआरएल
तो हमने यहां पे क्या किया बेस यूआरएल यूज
कर लिया अब बेस यूआरएल के बाद यहां पे
हमने एक स्लैश दे दिया स्लैश देके अब हमें
क्या करना है
कॉन्फिन यही तो फाइल चाहिए कॉड जन तो हमने
यहां पे मेंशन कर दिया ठीक है बस
दैट्ची होगा जो भी आपका टारगेट होगा वही
यहां पे आ जाएगा जैसे अगर हेलो बिग हेलोड
आ है तो बिग h.in config.js के लिए कोई
चीज आप मेंशन करना चाहते हैं यहां पे सो
दिस इज
द वेरिएबल
फॉर वेरिएबल फॉर द इनपुट
टारगेट बाय यूजर ऐसे करके आप लिख सकते हैं
ठीक है तो यह हमने क्या किया हमने यहां पे
पाथ यहां पे डिफाइन कर दिया अब पाथ के बाद
यहां पे आप चाहे तो हेडर्स भी डिफाइन कर
सकते हैं इफ यू वांट यू कैन जस्ट टाइप ऑन
हेडर्स जो भी आप हेडर्स चाहते हैं जो इस
रिक्वेस्ट के साथ आप चाहते हैं जाए तो आप
डिफाइन कर सकते हैं आपको नहीं डिफाइन करना
है कोई टेंशन नहीं इसके बाद आप डायरेक्टली
जो है आप मैच कंडीशंस प आ सकते हैं यानी
कि जो हमने बताया जो हमने देखा था मैचर्स
कंडीशंस कंडीशन उस परे आप आ सकते हैं तो
अब देखिए यहां प मैचस कंडीशंस में क्या
होगा
मैचस कंडीशन में यहां पे क्या होगा अब हम
एंड का यूज करेंगे मैचेस कंडीशन में हम
एंड यूज करेंगे अब देखो मैचेस कंडीशंस में
क्या है मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं
ठीक है आई एम गुड आईम
गुड हाय सर र बग बाउटी क्लास इ ऑसम यू मेक
कप्लेक्स लिटी इजी टू अंडरस्टैंड फनि
ग्रेट रिसोर्स फॉर एस्पायरिंग बग हंटर
थैंक्स फॉर द लबल
कंटेंट थैंक यू वालिद फॉर से दिस व थैंक
यू सो मच एंड यू आर मोस्ट वेलकम
राइट
चलिए ऑफलाइन क्लास की फी कितनी अभी आने दो
यार
अभी आने दो ठीक है ऑफलाइन अभी आने दो देन
व विल बी अनाउंसिंग एवरीथिंग ऑफ दैट
पर्टिकुलर ऑफलाइन सिस्टम ठीक है तो अभी
यहां पे मैंने
आपको इस वाली वेबसाइट प आप आ गए इस वाली
लिंक प मैचेस प जब आप आएंगे तो यहां पे
मैचेस में मैचेस अलाउ डिफरेंट टाइप ऑफ
फ्लेक्सिबल कंपैरिजन ऑन प्रोटो ऑन
प्रोटोकॉल रिस्पांसस जो प्रोटोकॉल के
रिस्पांसस है उसपे अलग-अलग तरह के
कंपैरिजन जो है आप इसके थ्रू कर कर सकते
ठीक
है दे आर व्ट मेक्स न्यूक्लि सो पावरफुल
चेक्स आर वेरी सिंपल टू राइट एंड मल्टीपल
चेक्स कैन बी एडेड एज पर द वेरी इफेक्टिव
स्कैनिंग अभी मैचेस में देखो जैसे क्या है
स्टेटस साइज वर्ड रेक्स बाइनरी डीएसएल
एक्स पाथ यह सारे मैचस है जिनका आप यूज कर
सकते हैं ठीक
है यहां प यू कैन यूज दिस राइट अब यहां पर
मैचेस में अब कैसे यूज करेंगे यहां पे
मैचेस हो गया उसका मैच मैच द स्टेटस कोर
ठीक है टाइप स्टेटस में स्टेटस कोर्स के
लिए यहां पे यहां पे स्टेटस में क्या है
सम स्टेटस कोड्स वी वांट टू मैच तो 200
3002 ऐसे जो भी स्टेटस कोड्स है वो मैच
यहां पे करने के लिए यहां पे हम दे देंगे
ठीक है तो भ यहां पे मैचेस कंडीशंस में हम
यहां पे यूज कर रहे हैं एंड अब यहां पे हम
डिफाइन करेंगे मैचस अब यहां पे हम क्या
डिफाइन करने वाले हैं मैचस इसको ध्यान
दीजिएगा ध्यान से देखिएगा मैचेस के अंदर
में आता है तो हम यहां पे इसके अंदर में
डैश देके यहां पे टाइप करें
टाइप अब हम कौन सा मैच करेंगे कंडीशन भैया
हम च कंडीशन वी वांट टू मैच तो भैया हमें
मैच करना है स्टेटस सॉरी स्टैटस क्योंकि
भैया यह जो फाइल है मुझे यह जो फाइल है
कॉन्ग जस यह मुझे जब मिले तो उसका यूआरएल
जब वो यूआरएल मिले तो वो 200 स्टेटस कोड
सॉरी एक सेकंड 200 स्टेटस कोड उसका होना
चाहिए तभी तो वो एक्टिव यूआरएल होगी ना
200 स्टेटस कोड नहीं होगा तो वो एक्टिव
कहां से होगी ठीक है 502 होगा या आपका 400
होगा तो फिर वो दिक्कत आएगी ना फिर थोड़ी
सी है ना राइट तो या 404 हो गया तो 200
स्टेटस कोन होना चाहिए तो हमने यहां पे
टाइप को मेंशन किया है स्टेटस कि हम
स्टेटस देखना चाहते हैं भैया अब भैया हम
यहां पे टाइप के अंदर में हम क्या देखना
चाहते हैं तो हम स्टेटस को देखना चाहते
हैं अब स्टेटस के अंदर भी हम क्या देखना
चाहते हैं कौन सा स्टेटस तो 200 हम देखना
चाहते हैं दैट्ची
कर देंगे या हम 301 देखना चाहते हैं 302
देखना चाहते हैं वो भी डिफाइन कर देंगे तो
हमें फिलहाल यहां पे 200 वाली जो स्टेटस
कोड्स हैं बस हमें वो चाहिए था तो हमने
यहां पे वो चीज मेंशन कर दिया
दैट्ची मान लो हमें हमारे फाइल मिल गई
हमारी ये फाइल config.js में 200 ओके वाली
200 वाली फाइल हमारी ये मिल गई config.js
मिल गई हमारे पास अब हमें क्या करना है
नाउ व्हाट तो अब हमें उसके अंदर सेंसिटिव
कोई इंफॉर्मेशन भी देखनी है भैया इफ यू
वांट कोई इंफॉर्मेशन सेंसिटिव चाहिए तो अब
सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन के लिए क्या करेंगे
तो उसके लिए हम फिर से एक मैचर यूज करने
वाले हैं और उस मैचर का नाम क्या देख देने
वाले हम यहां पे करने वाले हैं टाइप यह हो
जाएगा वड तो भैया मुझे अब क्या करना है
मुझे एक वर्ड वाली मैचर लगानी है वर्ड मैच
करनी चाहिए बट यह वर्ड कहां होगी कहां
मिलेगी तब हम इसको यूज कर में आए तो तो हम
इस वर्ड को कहां यूज करेंगे तो इस वर्ड को
हम इस वर्ड को हम इसका जो पार्ट होगा वर्ड
का वो क्या होगा बॉडी में होगा इस वर्ड का
जो पार्ट होगा वो कहां होगा बॉडी के अंदर
में होगा तो बॉडी के अंदर में भी फिर किस
टाइप का वर्ड होगा तो भैया होंगे ना
वर्ड्स होंगे यार बॉडी के अंदर वर्ड्स
होंगे सिंपल सा फंडा है तो वर्ड्स होंगे
तो मैं अब यहां पे थोड़ा सा इसको ऊपर की
तरफ स्क्रॉल कर देता हूं ताकि आपको दिखे
वड्स होंगे अब वर्ड्स के अंदर में चीजें आ
रही है तो यहां पे भैया ये करके वर्ड्स
में क्या आ जाए मान लो पासवर्ड आ
जाए ठीक है मान लो पासवर्ड आ जाए तो ये
हमने वर्ड दे दिया अब हमें एक चीज आ जाए
एपीआई की आ जाए ये भी एक वर्ड हो गया तो
इस तरीके से हम वर्ड्स को मेंशन कर सकते
हैं यहां पे बॉडी के अंदर यानी कि बॉडी के
अंदर ये वर्ड्स अगर हैं तो भी भैया हमें
आपको क्या करनी है चलानी है यानी कि 200
हो स्टेटस कोड और बॉडी के अंदर ये वर्ड हो
तो आपको इसको एग्जीक्यूट करना है यानी कुछ
लाके देना है अगर ये नहीं देंगे तो सिर्फ
200 वाली अगर मिल रही है तो हमें वो सिर्फ
फाइल लाके दे देगा बट हमें स्पेसिफिक कोई
करना है तो हम वर्ड को भी इसके अलावा आप
टाइप में रिजेक्स भी लगा सकते हैं एडिशनल
आप फिल्टर लगा सकते हैं एडिशनल आप मैचर
लगा सकते हैं रेक्स का यूज करके आप
अलग-अलग पैटर्स बना के जिस टाइप के पैटर्न
को चाहे फिल्टर आउट करके एंड वो पैटर्न
क्रिएट करके वो पैटर्न को यहां पे मैचर
में डाल के उस पैटर्न के अकॉर्डिंग जो है
आप चीजों को एग्जीक्यूट करा सकते हैं आपने
जो टेंप्लेट है उसको एक्यूट करा सकते हैं
ठीक है यह तो आपकी मैचर की बात हो गई अब
यहां पे हम आते
हैं कहां गई एक्सट्रैक्टर्स ठीक है
एक्सट्रैक्टर्स आर वेरी इंपोर्टेंट अब
एक्सट्रैक्टर्स क्या करते हैं रिव्यू
डिटेल्स ऑन एक्सट्रैक्टर्स फॉर न्यूक्लि
आई तो इसमें क्या है एक्सट्रैक्टर्स कैन
बी यूज टू एक्सट्रैक्ट एंड डिस्प्ले इन
रिजल्ट्स अ मैच फ्रॉम रिस्पांस रिटर्न बाय
द मॉड्यूल तो यह जो भी रिस्पांस मिलता है
ना उसमें मैच करेंगे एक्सट्रैक्टर्स
का यूज करके उस पर्टिकुलर चीज के लिए मैच
करेंगे जब मैच करेंगे अगर वो मैच कर रही
है तो वो हमें उठा के दे दगा अब इसके लिए
क्या क्या मैच कर सकते हैं ये रेक्स को की
वैल्यू पेयर के लिए कर सकते हैं ये जेसन
के लिए कर सकते हैं डीएसएल एक्सप्रेशंस के
लिए कर सकते हैं एक्स पाथ के लिए कर सकते
हैं तो आपका रेक्स और की वैल्यू पेयर और
जेसन में ही तो सारी चीजें आ जाती है एक
तरह से देखा जाए तो मतलब देखा जाए तो
रेक्स के अंदर सब कुछ है की वैल्यू पेयर
में आपकी सारी चीजें आ गई जेसन के अंदर
आपकी सारी चीजें आ गई तो ये तीनों मोस्टली
आपका जो यहां पे मैचर है पर्टिकुलर
एक्सट्रैक्टर है सॉरी वो यहां प यूज में
आता है ठीक है तो अब हम यहां पर चाहे तो
एक्स्टेक्स्ट भी यहां पर डिफाइन कर सकते
हैं इफ यू वांट यू कैन जस्ट डिफाइन द
एक्सट्रैक्टर ठीक है अब एक्स्टेक्स्ट को
कैसे यूज करेंगे तो ये किसके साथ अलाइन
होगा ये हमारे होगा सॉरी मैचस के साथ अलाउ
अलाइन तो एक्सट्रैक्टर्स जो है यहां पे
हमने एक्सट्रैक्टर्स पास ऑन किया राइट तो
एक्सट्रैक्टर्स को हम कैसे करेंगे भैया अब
एक्सट्रैक्टर्स को सेम मैचर्स की तरह यूज
करना है जो आपका मैचर है जिस तरीके से
आपने मैचर को यूज किया टाइप बताया पार्ट
बताया उसी तरीके से आपको यूज करना है तो
अब एक्सट्रैक्टर्स में भैया हमें क्या
चाहिए सॉरी क्योंकि इसके अंदर में टाइप कर
रहे हैं तो हमें इसका टाइप चाहिए तो टाइप
भाई हमें वर्ड चाहिए ठीक है टाइप वर्ड लिख
या रेक्स लिख लो रेक्स कर लो स्ट्रक्चर्स
में आप टाइप में रेजेस कर लो राइट अब ये
रेजेस किसके अंदर चाहिए सॉरी ये रेजेस
किसके अंदर चाहिए भैया पार्ट पार्ट तो
पार्ट चाहिए बॉडी के अंदर में ठीक है हमें
क्या चाहिए बॉडी के अंदर में रेक्स चाहिए
अब क्या एजेक्ट रेक्स आपको चाहिए मतलब
आपको रेक्स किस तरीके का क्रिएट करना है
किस तरीके का आपको रेक्स बनाना है उस परे
डिपेंड करता है राइट तो आपको रेक्स किस
तरीके से क्रिएट करना है वो आपके ऊपर में
है आप डिफरेंट डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ रेज
क्रिएट कर सकते हैं वो टोटली आपके ऊपर
डिपेंड करता है आप किस तरह का रेजे या
एक्सप्रेशन जो है वो क्रिएट करना चाहते
हैं अब देखो यहां पे मेरे को अगर मान लो
चाहिए मेरे को मान लो
अगर मेरे पास एक की वल पेयर आ गई मान लो
आपने सर्च किया अब हम एपीआई की एंड
पासवर्ड ये सर्च कर रहे हैं और मेरे पास
एक मान लो एक एग्जांपल है जैसे मेरे पास
ऐसे पास
वर्ड एंड पासवर्ड में है लव यू टूथ यह
पासवर्ड है अब यह मेरा आट यह मेरे को एक
पूरा का पूरा एक्सप्रेशन है मेरा ये इस
तरीके का इस तरीके का ठीक है पासवर्ड की
वैल्यू क्या है की वैल्यू पेयर आप बोल स
सकते एक तरह से एक तरह से की वैल्यू पेयर
आप बोल लीजिए की वैल्यू पेयर ठीक है तो
पासवर्ड की वैल्यू क्या है लव यूथ अब मुझे
रिजल्ट में यह पासवर्ड की वैल्यू
चाहिए यह पासवर्ड की वैल्यू यानी कि इसी
तरीके से मुझे चाहिए पर्टिकुलर कि मुझे यह
वाली वैल्यू इस तरीके से यहां पे डिफाइन
होके मिले इस तरीके से चीजें मेरे पास आए
रिजल्ट में इसके लिए मुझे रेगुलर
एक्सप्रेशन लिखना है रेगुलर एक्सप्रेशन
लिखना है इसके लिए प और इस इस रेगुलर
एक्सप्रेशन में हम यहां पर क्या च करेंगे
पासवर्ड एंड एपीआई की के लिए हम यहां पर
लिखेंगे तो पासवर्ड के लिए आप किस तरीके
का रेगुलर एक्सप्रेशन लिखेंगे और एपीआई के
लिए क्या लिखेंगे मान लो अगर मुझे पासवर्ड
के लिए लिखना है तो क्या लिखेंगे किसी को
एनी वन हैव आईडिया ऑफ रेगुलर एक्सप्रेशंस
वो यहां पर अपनी नॉलेज को प्रदान कर सकते
हैं चैट में बताइए मुझे इसके लिए मैं एक
इसका बताइए एक सिंपल कि पासवर्ड के लिए
मैं क्या रेगुलर एक्सप्रेशन लिखूंगा बताइए
पासवर्ड के लिए फिर एी के लिए भी सेम हम
अप्लाई कर देंगे दोनों में सेम ही अप्लाई
कर देंगे कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
ठीक है कोई बात नहीं अथर गुजर
चलेगा बताइए किसी को कि कोई है यहां पर
रेगुलर एक्सप्रेशन के बारे में जानकारी
रखने वाला एनी वन कोई है तो बताइए अगर कोई
ट्राई कर रहा है तो बता दीजिए पहले कि यू
आर ट्रांग देन आप ट्राई कीजिए
प्लीज
बताइए कोई ट्राई कर रहा है रेगुलर
एक्सप्रेशन के
लिए एनी
वन इफ यू आर ट्रांग फॉर द रेग मे भी क्रंच
टाइप क्या क्रच
टाइप रेगुलर एक्सप्रेशन आपने कभी क्रिएट
किया आप लोग में से किसी ने किसी ने
रेगुलर एक्सप्रेशन क्रिएट किया क्या पहले
बताइए हा तो इसका
बताइए रूट कोड ब्रदर आप बारबार अगर बोलोगे
कि प्रशन तो उससे प्र वीडियो नहीं आ जाएगी
वो मेरे अकॉर्डिंग जब जिस तरीके से चाहिए
वैसे मैं लेकर आऊंगा आप बस फॉलो कीजिए जो
चीज आ रही है ठीक है डोंट गो बिहाइंड एनी
सिंगल पर्टिकुलर टॉपिक वेरी रे सली कोई
फायदा नहीं है
उसका हां वो भी आ जाएगी टेंशन मत
लीजिए नितेश सर सब एडवांस टूल तो आप यहां
करवा रहे हो वीपीटी में क्या करवाओ ग ऐसा
कुछ नहीं है कि वीपीटी में और इसमें बहुत
जमीन आसमान का अंतर है वीपीटी इज कंपलीटली
डिफरेंट थिंग दिस इज बग बाउंट एंड मोर
स्पेसिफिकली दिस इज वेब एप्लीकेशन
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग दैट वी आर लर्निंग
वीपीटी इंक्लूड कंप्लीट एडवांस डब्ल्यू ए
पीटी कंप्लीट नेटवर्क पन टेस्टिंग कंप्लीट
ए प आई पेन टेस्टिंग अ लॉट ऑफ थिंग्स आर
देयर तो कोई कंपैरिजन नहीं करना है ठीक
है करेक्ट करेक्ट करेक्ट तो हम यहां पे ना
रेगुलर एक्सप्रेशन यहां पे क्रिएट करेंगे
मान लो हम यहां पे अब रेगुलर एक्सप्रेशन
क्रिएट करते हैं मान लो वी आर गोइंग टू
क्रिएट अ रेगुलर एक्सप्रेशन यहां पे
पासवर्ड के लिए अगर हम रेगुलर एक्सप्रेशंस
यहां पे क्रिएट करना चाहे पासवर्ड के की
वैल्यू पेयर के लिए मान लो कोई पासवर्ड आ
रही है मेरे पास जैसे इस तरीके से पासवर्ड
आ रही है तो इसका हम की वैल्यू पेयर किस
तरीके से रेगुलर एक्सप्रेशन में क्रिएट
करेंगे आपको पता है सबसे पहले ये आपको
यहां पे ये कॉलन दिख रहा है कॉलन कॉलन
राइट ये कॉलन दिख रहा है सबसे पहला यहां
पे पासवर्ड के बाद यहां पे क्या है कॉलन
है तो हम यहां पे एक कॉलन यहां पे मेंशन
कर देंगे राइट सिंपल उसके बाद यहां पे
वाइट स्पेस यहां पे आप प्रोवाइड करेंगे
स्ल s करेंगे नो स्पेस सिंपल सा फंडा है
इस तरीके से आप वाइट स्पेस के लिए करेंगे
एंड उसके बाद आप यहां पे स्टार मतलब
एवरीथिंग यहां पे डिफाइन कर देंगे व आर
डूइंग वी आर डूइंग लाइक काइंड ऑफ एवरीथिंग
मतलब जो भी है वो सारी चीजें यहां पे आप
मेंशन कर दीजिए मतलब ये कहने का मतलब है
जो भी है सारी चीजें ठीक है
दैट्ची कर जाएगी इसलिए हमने ये स्ल s
स्टार जो है वो दे दिया कॉलन कॉलन से मैच
कर गया सिंपल सा फंडा है ट्स इट ठीक है अब
हम यहां पे एक डबल कोट यहां पर दे देंगे
डबल कोट कौन सा यह वाला जो हमने डबल कोट
यहां पर दिया वो डबल कोट दे देंगे ठीक है
जो ओपनिंग कोटेशन मार्क है उसके लिए
ओपनिंग कोटेशन मार्क है बस उसके लिए देंगे
और कुछ भी नहीं है ठीक है तो हमने ओपन एंड
कोटेशन मार्क के लिए ये दे दिया अब हमें
यहां पे पर्टिकुलर क्या चाहिए नाउ वी नीड
द एक्चुअल डाटा ठीक है जो वैल्यू है ना वो
चाहिए व वैल्यू चाहिए तो उस वैल्यू को हम
डबल कोट के अंदर में या डबल ऐसे हां डबल
यहां पे डबल कोट नहीं यहां पे जो ब्रैकेट
है डबल ब्रैकेट उसके अंदर में यहां पे
वैल्यू असाइन करेंगे अब उस वैल्यू के लिए
यहां पे हम यहां पे पहले तो डॉट दे देते
हैं सभी जो उसके उसके लिए वैल्यू के लिए
जो हम ये कर रहे हैं एंड यहां पे क्वेश्चन
मार्क ये जो कहती है सिंपल सा फंडा है कि
इनसाइड कोट कोट के अंदर में जो भी चीजें
हैं सारी चीजों को यहां पे कैप्चर कर लो
जितने भी चीजें हैं वो सब कैप्चर कर लो
ठीक है ना दैट्ची करना है और इसके बाद
आपको दे देते हैं यहां पे कॉलन जो से डबल
कोट यहां पे जो इस डबल कोड को डिफाइन करती
है तो रेगुलर एक्सप्रेशन में आप एक-एक
टर्म्स को यहां पे डिफाइन करते हो तो सबसे
पहले हमने कॉलन दे दिया कॉलन को डिफाइन
किया स्पेस के लिए हमने जो मैच कर रही है
वो स्ल ए स्टार दे दिया यहां पे एवरीथिंग
फिर यहां पे डबल कोड के लिए यहां पे हमने
डबल कोड तैयार किया फिर हमने जो इसके अंदर
में जो भी कंटेंट है उसके लिए हमने यह
पूरा कंटेंट तैयार कर लिया ये कंटेंट उसको
मैच कर जाएगी एंड यहां पे हमने फिर डबल
कोड दे दिया तो ये हमारा एक रेगुलर
एक्सप्रेशन तैयार हो गया है हम इसको
सिंपली क्या करेंगे वी विल बी पुटिंग
इनसाइड दिस रेक्स के अंदर में तो हम अब
क्या करेंगे रेक्स के अंदर में इसको हम
सिंपली पुट डाउन कर देंगे
दैट्ची चीज है तो यहां पे डैश एंड उसके
बाद यहां पे इसको जो है हमेशा डबल या जो
भी है आप सिंगल कोड के अंदर में यहां पे
डाल सकते हैं ठीक है अब इसके अंदर में
आपको यहां पे देना है डबल कोड के
सॉरी पासवर्ड जो आपको एगजैक्टली पासवर्ड
चाहिए वो और उसको क्लोज कर दिया ट्स इट अब
हम यहां पर जो हमने वैल्यू वहां पर बनाई
थी वह वैल्यू यहां पर पुट डाउन कर देंगे
सिंगल कोड के अंदर यहां पर यह पूरी की
पूरी एक वैल्यू जो है वोह रिजेक्स
एक्सप्रेशन जो है वो क्रिएट हो गई पासवर्ड
के लिए सेम गोज फॉर द एपीआई तो यहां पर हम
सिंपल सा यहां पर कर दिया एंड यहां पर
हमने यहां पर एपीआई यहां पर मेंशन कर दी
ठीक है एपीआई वाली चीज हो गई अब यहां से
निकल के हमने सेम जो चीज थी वह यहां पे
यहां पे मेंशन कर दी एंड इसको क्लोज करके
ये हमने एक एक्सप्रेशन यानी रिजेक्स हमने
क्रिएट कर दिया रिजेक्स को भी बहुत अगर आप
सिंपली समझोगे करोगे तो सिंपली आप रिजेक्स
को भी समझ जाओगे बहुत बड़ी चीज नहीं है
बहुत सिंपल सा फंडा है तो हमें जो आउटपुट
चाहिए जिस तरीके से जैसे वो आउटपुट के लिए
हमने ये पासवर्ड के लिए एपीआई के लिए यहां
पे रक्स हमने तैयार कर दिया दैट्ची
यू कैन से वाई एमएल या एमएल लैंग्वेज में
हमने पूरी की पूरी एक कस्टम कोड हमने लिख
दिया है अब आपका यह जो कस्टम कोड है एकदम
एब्सलूट रेडी टू यूज है और आप इसको किसी
भी टारगेट यूआरएल पे बेसिकली चला सकते हैं
बट वहां पे आपका पासवर्ड या एपीआई की जो
है वो कॉन्फिन फाइल में आपकी होनी चाहिए
तब जाके ये काम करेगा आपकी अदर वाइज इट
विल नॉट वर्क ठीक है तो ऐसा कोई टारगेट है
तो आपका ये काम करेगा तो ये पूरी की पूरी
आप देखो आप हमने इतना हमने इतना लंबा सा
लंबा सा क्या बहुत लंबा नहीं है छोटा सा
हमने कोड लिखा बट आपको पता भी नहीं चला
लाइक हमें एहसास भी नहीं हुआ ज्यादा कि
क्या इतना कुछ कोड का हमने कितना कुछ कोड
भी लिख दिया हमने तो हमने सारा चीज लिख भी
दिया तो ये एक-एक स्टेप वाइज जब जाएंगे ना
तो बहुत चीजें आसान हो जाती है ठीक है तो
वी बेसिकली रोट डाउन अ कस्टम न्यूक्लि
टेंप्लेट ये मैंने बहुत सिंपल सा टेंप्लेट
आपको एग्जांपल के थ बनाया बताया ताकि आपको
समझ में आ जाए कि कैसे लिखना है अब आप
इसके ऊपर में आपकी वो स्किल है आपके वो
प्रैक्टिसेस हैं और आपकी वो
लाइक कि आप किस तरीके से कितना
कॉम्प्लेक्टेड जो है किसी सीवी का को पढ़
के पीसी को यूज करके पीसी को समझ के उसके
लिए टेंप्लेट बना दे रहे हो जो किसी और ने
नहीं बनाया किसी और ने बनाया आप बेटर बना
दे रहे हो तो वो आपके ऊपर में टोटली ठीक
है यह आपको समझ में आ रहा
है थैंक
यू सर इज इ टू लेट टू लर्न साइबर
सिक्योरिटी कुछ नहीं है ऐसा कुछ लेट नहीं
है य गुड गुड टू गो राइट
नाउ एवरीवन
अंडरस्टैंड लव फ्रॉम बांग्लादेश इज दिस
प्लेलिस्ट इनफ टू लर्न कंप्लीट बग बाउंट
दिस प्लेलिस्ट इज एंड विल बी इनफ टू
कंप्लीट योर बग बाउंट जर्नी स्पेशली इन
डब्ल्यू एपीडी बट इसमें हम और भी चीजें
कवर करेंगे आने वाले टाइम में ठीक है कुछ
कुछ चीज डब्ल्यू ए पीटी में ही यार इतनी
चीजें है ना कि कवर करते करते एक पूरा
जमाना खत्म हो जाएगा ब डब्ल्यू ए पीटी
खत्म नहीं होने वाली है तो डोंट वरी हम
डब्ल्यू ए पीटी को नेक्स्ट लेवल पर लेके
जाने वाले इस पर्टिकुलर सीरीज के थ्रू
डब्ल्यू ए पीटी को बहुत इन डेप्थ हम कवर
करेंगे ठीक
है ठीक है समझ में आ
गया
चलिए ओके सो
ओके तो हमने फाइनली यहां पर टेंप्लेट जो
है यहां पर कोड कर लिया है अब इसको
एग्जीक्यूट करने का टाइम आ चुका है जब
आपने लिख लिया यहां
पर आई होप सभी चीज हमने सही यहां पर मेंशन
करी है तो अब आप इसको स्केप प्रेस करके
कॉलन डबल क करके सेव कर लीजिए जब आप सेव
कर लेंगे देन यू आर गुड टू गो अब ये
टेंप्लेट आपके डेस्कटॉप पे ही सेव है
कॉन्ग जनवा से अब न्यूक्लि में आपको यूज
करना है किसी भी टारगेट के लिए तो नलि हान
य और वो टारगेट दे दीजिए जैसे एटीपीए कॉलन
बिग
हेलोड टारगेट दिया मैंने न t दिया
टेंप्लेट का यूज कर लीजिए
दैट्ची जिए अदर वाइज इतना काफी है और एंटर
कर दीजिए नाउ देखते हैं यहां पे दैट्ची
तो हमें यहां पे कुछ भी यहां पे देखने को
नहीं मिला है तो जब भी आप कोई रिजल्ट अगर
मिलेगा उसके डि मैचिंग मिलेगा तो आप यहां
पे यूज कर सकते हैं ये यूज़ में आ जाएगा
सिंपल अब आप इसको सिंपली टेंप्लेट के
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
यूज़ करेंगे तो ये टेंप्लेट ऑटोमेटिक यूज़
होगा सेंसिटिव डाटा या जो भी टैग्स हमने
दिए थे उसके लिए अब फिर से इसको पढ़ना है
तो यहां पे विम कॉन्फिन आए और यहां पे इस
टेंप्लेट को आप बेसिकली पढ़ सकते हैं या
फिर आप कैट भी कर दीजिए कॉन्ग ड ज तो आप
इस टेंप्लेट को यहां पर भी कंपलीटली पढ़
सकते हैं तो यह टेंप्लेट हमने यहां पर बना
लिया ट्स इट तो कितना इजी था ना टेंप्लेट
को क्रिएट करना यह बता दीजिए इट वाज
इजी इट वास इजी
टू क्रिएट अ
टेंपलेट परमानेंट पीसी थैंक यू सर आप हम
सबको फ्री में नॉलेज दे रहे हैं थैंक यू
सो मच यू आर मोस्ट वेलकम एंड आई होप कि आप
सीखें इस फ्री नॉलेज से इसको आप
अ उस तरीके का वैल्यू दे इसको वर्थ बनाए
क्योंकि वर्थ आप ही बनाएंगे
राइट व्हि प्लेटफॉर्म इज गुड अकॉर्डिंग टू
यू सर हैकर ऑन बक राउड माय फेवरेट इज हैकर
वन दोनों सही है दोनों सही लगते हैं मुझे
तो राइट चलो
ठीक
है चलिए तो इस तरीके से हमने यहां पे
टेंप्लेट बना लिया एंड हमने टेंप्लेट को
यहां पे कस्टम टेंप्लेट न्यूक्लि का खुद
का एक कस्टम टेंप्लेट डिजाइन कर लिया अब
सबसे बड़ी बात यह है कि न्यूक्लि के कस्टम
टेंप्लेट में जो हमने यूज़ किया सिर्फ
इतना ही नहीं है न्यूक्लि के जब आप
टेंप्लेट गाइड को पढ़ेंगे तो आपको पूरा का
पूरा यहां पे बहुत डिटेल में लाइक फजिंग
के लिए एक सिंपल लेबिलिटी डिटेक्शन के लिए
अंदर आएंगे रिक्वेस्ट अलग-अलग तरह के जो र
रिक्वेस्ट आते हैं एसटीडीपी के या जो
एडवांस है रिक्वेस्ट हैं जो सिंपल बेसिक
एसटीडीपी रिक्वेस्ट है वो सारे चीजें आप
यहां पे डिफाइन यहां पे बेसिकली इनफैक्ट
यू कैन अ डिफाइन जो फज से रिलेटेड जो भी
आपके कीवर्ड्स हैं या जो भी आपके पेलोड है
वो आप पे लोट्स भी यहां पे एक-एक करके पलट
की लिस्ट भी बना सकते हैं पूरी की पूरी
एंड पेलो की लिस्ट भी यहां पे डाल सकते
हैं या तो आप चाहे तो आप इसको एक फाइल से
फेच कर सकते हैं ठीक है एक फाइल के थ्रू
जैसे आप यहां पे देख सकते हैं अगर आपको फज
का यहां पे आपको क्या है है फज की
रिक्वेस्ट डालनी है तो रीडायरेक्ट ट्रू है
अटैक जो भी अटैक मोड यूज करेंगे पेलोड
यहां पे फज का जो पेलोड है वो एक
रिक्वेस्ट पाथ जो है व वहां से उठाएगा
जहां पे आपकी पूरी फजिंग की एक तरह से
जैसे आप एफएफ यूएफ वगैरह यूज करते हैं अ
फजिंग वगैरह के लिए तो आप टेंप्लेट का भी
यूज कर सकते हैं न्यूक्लि आई का और वहां
पे आप अपनी टेंप्लेट के अंदर में उस
पर्टिकुलर पेलोड को या फजिंग
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री सा देर मैचेस में बहुत
सारी चीजें होती है तो आप इन मैचेस को भी
यूज कर सकते हैं और भी बहुत सारे कीवर्ड्स
है जो आप इसको पढ़ेंगे तो आपको बहुत
ज्यादा इसकी नॉलेज मिलेगी आप जितना अच्छे
से इसको पढ़ेंगे उतना ज्यादा नॉलेज आपको
मिलेगी जितनी टेंपलेट्स को आप पढ़ेंगे
उतनी ज्यादा आपको नॉलेज मिलेगी नाउ अगर
मैं आपको एक एग्जांपल के तौर पे दिखाऊ
यहां पे न्यूक्लि के अंदर में ही चलते
हैं न्यूक्लि के अंदर में ही हम इसके एक
टेंप्लेट को देखते
हैं फजिंग में चलते हैं फजिंग में अब
फजिंग में चलते हैं कैश पॉइजनिंग है यहां
पे वर्डप्रेस वीक क्रेडेंशियल चलो
वर्डप्रेस वीक क्रेडेंशियल का फजिंग है
यहां पे हम इसको यहां पे करते हैं इसको
जूम करते हैं जूम इन कर लेते हैं थोड़ा सा
जब आप इसको देखोगे तो आप देखो यहां पे
कौन-कौन सी टर्म आईडी यूज की है इंफो में
नेम ऑथर सवेरिस्क िप्स रेफरेंस
क्लासिफिकेशन भी यहां पे इंफो के अंदर
आपकी आ रही है इसके अंदर में भी फिर
सीवीएसएस सीबीएसएस मैट्रिक्स है यहां पे
सीबीएसएस स्कोर है यहां पे सीडब्ल्यू आईडी
है यहां पे फिर इसके अंदर आप मेटा डेटा को
यूज कर सकते हैं जी हां आप फिर मेटा डेटा
भी डिफाइन कर सकते हैं ठीक है रेफरेंस के
अंदर में तो यहां पे आपने रेफरेंस दे दिया
क्लासिफिकेशन में ये दे दिया आपने यहां पे
ठीक है ये सारे इंफो के अंदर में ही है
मेटा डाटा आप डिफाइन कर सकते हैं मैक्सिमम
रिक्वेस्ट डिफाइन कर सकते हैं टैग्स फिर
आप यहां पे आप दे सकते हैं इंफो के अंदर
में उसके बाद प्रोटोकॉल आपकी आएगी तो फिर
एसटीडीपी प्रोटोकॉल यहां पे अब कौन सी
एसटीडीपी प्रोटोकॉल है भैया तो ये रॉ
एसटीडीपी प्रोटोकॉल है तो भैया अब यहां से
शुरू हो रही है तो पन रिक्वेस्ट कैसी
जाएगी तो पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट आएगी w
login.php पे यहां पे होस्ट कौन होगा
होस्ट नेम यहां पे आ जाएगा ओरिजिन बेस
यूआरएल आ जाएगी कंटेंट टाइप आपकी आ गई
रेफरल आपका बेस यूआरएल आ जाएगा लॉग में
फिर यूजर्स एंड पासवर्ड में पासवर्ड्स
सिंपल लॉग में क्या करना है भैया यूजर्स
एंड पासवर्ड्स को लॉक करना है दैट्ची
हेल्पर्स के अंदर जाओगे तो यहां पर आपको
पेलोड्स मिल जाएंगे यहां पर आपको वर्ड
लिस्ट मिल जाएंगे अलग-अलग तरह के यह पूरे
की पूरी वर्ड लिस्ट है आपको एंड यहां पे
आपके वर्डप्रेस के अंदर के प्लगिंस के
सारी चीजें मिल जाएंगी तो यहां पे यह जो
यूज कर रहा है बेसिकली वो यहीं से यूज कर
रहा है हेल्पर्स के अंदर से ही वो
वर्डलिस्ट यूज हो रही है ठीक है तो मैं
फजन के अंदर में वर्डप्रेस वाली मैंने ओपन
की
थी तो यहां पे फजन अब यहां पे टैक्स दे
दिए दो तो बता ही दिया
था ठीक है ठीक है अब यूजर्स में तो ये
यूजर्स पासवर्ड्स यहां पे फिर से
वर्डलिस्ट w पावर्टी से स्टॉप एट फर्स्ट
मैच जो है वो टू है मतलब जैसे ही फर्स्ट
मैच आए तो ये रुक जाए फर्स्ट मैच पे यहां
पे रुकना है आपको अब यहां पे फिर फिर से
वही चीज डिफाइन कर दी है कि मैचेस का
मैचेस कंडीशन लगा दी एंड की एंड में मैचेस
में क्या डिफाइन किया है देखो ये एंड के
तरफ से है सिर्फ एंड वाली कंडीशन है तो
मैचेस में टाइप में वर्ड है पार्ट कहां
हेडर में वो वर्ड होनी चाहिए कौन से वर्ड
होनी चाहिए डपी एडमिन या वर्डप्रेस लगड इन
होनी चाहिए कंडीशन फिर एड में क्या है
टाइप स्टेटस होना चाहिए स्टेटस 302 होना
चाहिए ताकि वो रीडायरेक्शन वाली चीज अगर
कोई है तो वो चीज यहां पे कवर ठीक है
दैट्ची को देखोगे तो समझोगे ये तो
छोटी-छोटी टेंपलेट्स है अब एक्सपोजर में
आओ कॉफिक्स में आओ यहां पे मान लो
एक्सपोज गट इनोर डवा एएल इसको कर लो अब
इसमें एक अच्छा खासा पूरा दिया हुआ है आप
देखो यहां पे अच्छी खासी पूरी की पूरी
टेंपलेट्स दी गई है यहां पे मैचर कंडीशन
में टाइप में वर्ड वर्ड्स में अलग-अलग तरह
के जितने भी वर्ड्स हो सकते हैं वो सारे
वर्ड्स दिए हैं रिस्पांस में होने चाहिए
नेगेटिव ट्रू कंडीशंस और ठीक है बस हो गया
सिंपल तो ये सारी चीजें आप यहां पे डिफाइन
करके आप यहां कस्टम न्यूक्लियर टेंपलेट्स
बना सकते हो तो मैं मानता हूं कि न्यूक्लि
आई को कैसे यूज करना है आपको ये बता दिया
न्यूक्लि के अंदर में आपको रेट लिमिटिंग
का कितना बेनिफिट है ताकि आपके रिक्वेस्ट
को ब्लॉक ना किया जा सकते वो बता दिया एंड
एक चीज मैं सबसे इंपोर्टेंट चीज बता रहा
हूं यहां
पे नोट नेवर यूज
ऑल न्यूक्लि आई टेंपलेट्स
एट टी एम पी एल एटी टेंपलेट्स एट वंस ऑन
अ ऑन अ टारगेट
विदाउट रेट लिमिटिंग तो बिना रेट लिमिटिंग
का आपको न्यूक्लि के सारे टेंप्लेट एक ही
टारगेट पर यूज नहीं करना है ठीक है और
आपको नॉलेज नहीं है सही से तो आपको नहीं
आपको क्या करना है ना ओनली यूज
स्पेसिफिक न्यूक्लि आई टेंपलेट्स
अकॉर्डिंग टू
नीड अकॉर्डिंग टू
नीड फॉर द पर्टिकुलर
वलने बिलिटी जो भी आपका पर्टिकुलर वने
बिलिटी है उसके अकॉर्डिंग ही आप उस
न्यूक्लियर टेंप्लेट को जो है यूज कीजिए
जो भी आपके अब इस चीज को ऑटोमेट करना है
न्यूक्लि के अंदर में एक ऑटोमेशन की ताकत
है ऑटोमेशन ऑटोमेशन की ताकत है यह बहुत
इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है यह मैं आपको बता देता
हूं यहां पर ऑटोमेशन की ताकत है न्यूक्लि
के अंदर में आप चीजों को ऑटोमेट कर सकते
हो कैसे कर सकते हो मैं आपको एक इसका
एग्जांपल बता देता हूं न्यूक्लि हाफ
कीजिएगा तो इसमें एक ऑप्शन आपको आता
है न्यूक्लि के अंदर देखिए
यह बहुत अच्छी चीज है इसको आप यूज
फ्रीक्वेंसी
हां जी यह रहा एस यह जो आपका पर्टिकुलर
ऑप्शन है एस टेंप्लेट में एस यह है
ऑटोमेटिक स्कैन ऑटोमेटिक वेब स्कैन यूजिंग
वेपराइजर टेक्नोलॉजी डिटेक्शन टू टैग्स
मैपिंग इसका मतलब क्या है ना यह जब आप एस
का यूज कर रहे होते हैं तो आपका जो हाइन
एस जब आप यूज कर रहे हो तो आपका जो
न्यूक्लि आई है वह क्या करता है एक टारगेट
के लिए एक टारगेट के लिए पपलाज का यूज़
करता है ठीक है वेपराइजर अब वेपराइजर का
मतलब आपको पता ही है क्रम एक्सटेंशन है ये
बहुत पॉपुलर कम एक्सटेंशन है जैसे मान लो
कि मैंने यहां पे बिग हेलो डॉट बिग हेलो
ओपन
किया ठीक है अब यहां पे वेबलाइजर
एक्सटेंशन लगी है कम में अब मैं इसको जब
ओपन करूंगा तो यह इसकी डिटेल्स
टेक्नोलॉजिकल प्रोफाइल बताएगा कि ई-कॉमर्स
वेबसाइट है शफाई प होस्टेड है सीडीएन कौन
सी यूज हो रही है फोटो गैलरी में क्या है
टैग मैनेजर कौन सा यूज़ हो रहा है
सिक्योरिटी किस तरह की है जावास्क्रिप्ट
की कौन-कौन सी लाइब्रेरी यूज़ हो रही है
कौन सा फ्रेमवर्क यूआई के लिए यूज हो रहा
है और भी मिसलेनियस जो चीज है वो सारी चीज
आपको यहां पे बताएगा ठीक
है यह तो आपको समझ में आ गया अब इसी
वेलाइन का यूज करेगा एस टैग जैसे मान लो
आपने बताया न्यूक्लि आपने किया न्यूक्लि
अब यहां पे हान य दे दिया आपने बिग हेलो
डट आय अब आप यहां पे कुछ मेंशन मत करो मान
लो कुछ अभी मेंशन आपने नहीं किया अब क्या
करना है आपको हान ए दे देना है ऑटोमेटिक
स्कैनिंग के लिए अब ये क्या करेगा कि
पपलाज का यूज करेगा
और इस पूरी वेबसाइट की टेक्नोलॉजिकल
प्रोफाइल निकालेगा कि इसमें कौन-कौन सी
टेक्नोलॉजी यूज हो रही है और उस
टेक्नोलॉजी के अकॉर्डिंग जो जो टैग्स
होंगे उस परे मैप कर देगा यानी कि उस
टेक्नोलॉजी के अकॉर्डिंग कोई मान लो कि
जावास्क्रिप्ट की लाइब्रेरीज है तो
जावास्क्रिप्ट लाइब्रेरीज वाले टैग्स वाले
जितने भी जावास्क्रिप्ट वाले जितने भी
टैग्स वाले जो भी टेंपलेट्स होंगे वो सब
ऑटोमेटिक एग्जीक्यूट करेगा ये तो मैंने
यहां प हान एस करके मान लो एंटर कर दिया
अब देखते हैं ये देखो कैसे करेगा यह
देखो हो रहा है यहां पे अब यहां पे तुम
देख सकते हो यहां
पे न्यू टले टेंपलेट्स लोडेड फॉर करंट
स्कैन
8590 इतने सारे टेंपलेट्स को इसने लोड
किया यहां पे ऑटोमेटिक स्कैन टेक डिटेक्ट
टेक टेक्नोलॉजी डिटेक्ट किया इसने और यहां
पे अब ऑटोमेटिक स्कैन हो रही है तो ये
इतने सारे टेंपलेट्स को इसने डिटेक्ट किए
हैं जो इसके टेक्नोलॉजिकल प्रोफाइल को मैच
कर रहे हैं एंड इन टेंपलेट्स को ये
एग्जीक्यूट करता चलेगा तो आपको यहां पे
दिख रहा होगा कि यहां पे स्टार्ट होनी ये
डिटेक्ट होना और और इसके अकॉर्डिंग काम
करना ये शुरू कर चुका है जैसे टेक डिटेक्ट
में जेएस डिलीवर आ रहा है स्लिक आ रहा है
बूट स्ट्रैप आ रहा है क्लाउड फ्लेयर आ रहा
है क्लाउड फ्लेयर आ रहा है तो जैसे कि
हमने देखा था अभी वेपराइजर के ऊपर में
वैसे ही ये डिटेक्ट कर रहा है और उसके बाद
ये अपनी का जो कंप्लीट आपकी टेंप्लेट
एग्जीक्यूशन है वो स्टार्ट कर देगा एंड
फिर आपको रिजल्ट जो है वो आपको प्रोवाइड
करेगा तो कुछ इस तरीके से है जो आपका ये
काम करता है हान ए है ना कमाल की चीज हान
ए कैसा लगा आपको न ए बहुत ऑटोमेटिक चीज है
मतलब ऑटोमेट कर देता है आपको ज्यादा मेहनत
भी नहीं करनी है एक तरह से देखा जाए तो
राइट
मजा आ
गया ए पन टेस्टिंग की नेक्स्ट पेड बैच
आएगी नवंबर में आएगी ठीक है नवंबर में
उसकी अनाउंसमेंट होगी आपकी तो एवरीवन गट
आई होप एवरीवन अंडरस्टूड आल्सो राइट सभी
को समझ में भी आ गया
होगा तो तो यह हमारी डेनिक्स की वेबसाइट
है जहां पर आपको हमारी डेनिक्स के
रिगार्डिंग सारी अपडेट्स इस पर आपको मिलती
जाएंगी अपक बैचेज वगैरह सब कुछ यह अभी पेज
अपडेट भी होने वाला है यहां पे और बैचेज
ऐड होने वाले हैं इनकी टाइमिंग अपडेट्स
होने वाली है ये थोड़े पुराने टाइमिंग से
जो यहां पे लिखे हुए हैं तो ये अपडेट हो
जाएंगे क्योंकि आपको यहां पे इसका लाइक जो
एग्जैक्ट वो टेंटेटिव डेट होगा सॉरी वो
यहां पे मेंशन आ जाएगी यहां पे एंड यहां
पे सारे कोर्सेस भी हैं जो आपको दिखेंगे
यहां पे तो आप वेबसाइट को विजिट करते
रहिएगा रेगुलर अपडेट्स के लिए सारी
अपडेट्स आपको य यहीं पे मिलेंगी ठीक है
ओके तो चलिए आई होप कि सभी को समझ में आ
गया होगा तो आज के सेशन को यहां खत्म करते
हैं आई होप यू ऑल आर एंजॉयिंग द फेस्टिवल
एंड हैप्पी नवरात्रि हैप्पी दुर्गा पूजा
हैप्पी दशहरा सबको क्योंकि अब हम दशहरा के
बाद ही मिलेंगे तो एंड आई होप कि आप सब जो
है न्यूक्लि आई के दोनों वीडियो को दोनों
पार्ट को आप अच्छे से देखेंगे उसको
प्रैक्टिस करेंगे याद रखिएगा एक न्यूक्लि
टूल के कारण लोगों को बहुत सारी बाउंटीज
लगी है लिटरली मैं बता रहा हूं बहुत सारी
बाउंटीज लगी है तो आप जो है न्यूक्लि टूल
को हल्के में मत लीजिएगा अभी जब न्यूक्लि
की हमने वीडियो बनाई थी तो एक बंदे की
न्यूक्लि के कारण ही बाउंट लगी थी उसने
लिन प पोस्ट भी करा था वो मैंने आपको
या ल ल ट्राई वी आर ट्राइल हैं नेक्स्ट
सेशन में गाइस आई होप नेक्स्ट सेशन में
ज्यादा लोग होंगे अच्छे लोग यहां ज्यादा
लोग ज्यादा की मात्रा में आएंगे एंड ताकि
हम उसको कंटिन्यू कर पाए राइट थैंक यू सो
मच फॉर जॉइनिंग दिस सेशन गाइस लेट्स मीट
ऑन द नेक्स्ट सेशन थैंक यू सो मच हैव अ
गुड नाइट